Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaf und das hier ist Ausgabe Nummer achtzig und nach einer Sommerpause von
jetzt vier Wochen sind's ja eigentlich nur gewesen, weil wir zwischendurch nochmal kurz gesendet haben, gibt's heute mal wieder,
Corona Weekly. Mal gucken, wie Weekly das jetzt wird. Aber zumindest sind wir in äh Stammbesetzung und das ist natürlich außer mir,
auch noch Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Ja und äh.
Ein bisschen Sommer äh gehabt und haben so ein bisschen gedacht so, na gucke mal, die Inzidenzen, die sitzen wir jetzt aus. Ich weiß gar nicht.
Ja
Denn das letztes Jahr eigentlich im Vergleich, da sind wir doch irgendwie ein bisschen später dann wieder in die Spur geraten, aber irgendwie, ja.
Ja, letztes Jahr war alles besser.
Nein, nicht, nicht alles, aber.
Tja.
Aber letztes Jahr waren wir an die Zahlen früher runter und sind nicht so früh wieder angestiegen, aber gut ähm dafür, ja.
Haben wir's ja aber auch jetzt mit anderen Viren zu tun, immer noch dieselbe Familie, aber es hat sich natürlich jetzt hier
weiterversetzt und wie wir gleich auch noch äh erläutern werden, ist natürlich jetzt alles Delta. Alles Delta oder was.
Ja, was wollen wir heute machen? Also wir wollen natürlich jetzt mal ein wenig.
Zusammenkehren. Wir haben so einiges äh beobachtet so mit einem Auge und wollten mal so ein bisschen den Stand der Dinge erstmal festnageln, sodass wir dann uns vielleicht in den nächsten Wochen wieder mehr mit den Differenzen beschäftigen können.
Ja und versuchen natürlich auch ein paar der Fragen anzusprechen,
euch vielleicht auch so ein bisschen äh im Kopf schwirren. Wie ist die aktuelle Situation?
Überhaupt einzuschätzen, was ist jetzt hier eigentlich mit der Impfkampagne, wird das noch was oder wie äh wie gehen wir mit den Inzidenzen künftig um und wie mit dieser äh vierten Welle, die jetzt vor uns steht
Wird's denn überhaupt eine? Welche.
Gefahr geht jetzt von den neuen Varianten aus, was könnte da vielleicht noch Drohnen? Da haben wir natürlich nicht auf alles,
Antwort unbedingt, zumindest jetzt keine explizite, aber das sind so natürlich die Gedanken, die uns auch die ganze Zeit durch den äh Kopf gehen, nicht zuletzt auch so Fragen mit welche Regeln sollen denn jetzt eigentlich gelten,
wann kommt sie denn endlich? Die Normalisierung, was auch immer das sein mag.
Ja, das sind Fragen, die uns natürlich auch beschäftigen und ähm wir versuchen, das so ein bisschen mitzudenken.
Traditionell eröffnen wir aber dieses Gedankenfest immer mit dem Blick auf die Zahlen. Pavel, dein Einsatz. Wie sieht's denn aus?
Du
Na ja.
Du sammelst ja, das müssen wir vielleicht auch mal jetzt mal sagen, weil vielleicht haben wir ja auch ein paar neue Hörerinnen dazugewonnen. Ähm was wir jetzt hier eigentlich machen, seit einem halben Jahr ist ja äh so ein bisschen Zahlenmassage,
du sammelst die Daten vom RKI ein, rechnest sie selber durch, nach sozusagen und gewinnst aber auch
ein paar äh Einblicke und äh Analysen mit deinen Tools, die jetzt vielleicht so woanders nicht zu sehen sind oder zumindest hast du die Möglichkeit, fein äh reinzuschneiden und bei Bedarf bestimmte Aspekt
nochmal auszubuddeln, das werden wir jetzt auch gleich wieder machen.
Ähm genau und äh das machen wir natürlich jetzt auch weiter. So lange, so lange es noch Informationsbedarf gibt.
Ja. Also die Zahlen. Es gab ja viel,
Debatten über das Thema wie aussagekräftig ist denn jetzt eigentlich noch die Inzidenz, aber es ist halt nach wie vor ähm
so eine der wichtigsten Zahlen natürlich. Man will halt wissen, wie viel Leute äh tragen das Virus
in sich und sind potentiell ansteckend. Wir hatten das Meer oder werden es weniger? Insofern, da kann man halt so viel rum relativieren, wie man will. Das ist eine grundlegende
Information ähm die,
ja äh sage mal, den die wichtigste Information eigentlich und ähm nachdem wir,
ist ja, ja, so Anfang Juli dann den Tiefststand erreicht hatten mit in Deutschland,
Inzidenz von unter fünf. Hm.
Ist es halt seitdem wieder angestiegen und steigt,
weiter an und ja, wir sind halt jetzt beinahe Inzidenz von äh dreiundzwanzig, vierundzwanzig.
Nach Publikationsdatum Tendenz weiter steigend mit einem R-Wert, ja, der
schwankt so zwischen eins Komma null sieben, also einem Sieben-Tage-Airwert eins Komma null sieben und,
eins Komma zwei im Moment liegen mir bei eins Komma.
Eins fünf äh so, also eins Komma eins zwei nach Publikationsdatum. Wie gesagt, also kein.
Extrem hoher R-Wert, aber ja, äh schon deutlich über eins,
und äh ja, so marschiert das Ganze im Moment mehr oder weniger linear aussehend, aber äh
nach oben, wobei eben exponentielles Wachstum ähm am Anfang bei niedrigen.
Wir hatten äh dann je nachdem kann halt auch linear aussehen äh so, aber ähm ja.
Also es kann den Eindruck erwecken, es wäre linear, aber es trägt äh die exponentielle Power schon in sich.
Also wenn man sich so einen Hafen anschaut, kann man ihn nicht unbedingt am Anfang äh ansehen, äh dass das Exponentiell nach oben geht und ja.
Also Größenordnung, irgendwann mal fünfundzwanzig jetzt äh im Moment, was so also fünfundzwanzig,
neue äh Fälle pro hunderttausend Einwohner in den letzten sieben Tagen, um das auch nochmal äh vollständig die Definition äh dort wiederzugeben und zwar veröffentlicht.
Ja
Um das ein bisschen zu kontextualisieren. Ich weiß ja äh Vergleich hinkt ein ein wenig, trotzdem denke ich, ist das eine ganz schöne Gedankenbrücke, wenn man jetzt mal die Inzidenz des letzten Jahres vergleichen, vor der zweiten Welle,
ja? Da hatten wir dann auch irgendwann mal so eine Inzidenz. Ja, und auch so einen ähnlichen Anstieg, der vielleicht,
etwas flacher war, als der, den wir jetzt sehen und ähm wenn wir uns jetzt ins letzte Jahr beamen, dann sind wir so ungefähr auf Mitte Oktober.
Zehnter zehnter Oktober und das ist so der Zeitraum, von dem wir dann im Nachgang immer wieder festgehalten haben, da hätte im Prinzip,
unser Lockdown
greifen müssen, ne. Ich sage nicht, jetzt muss der Lockdown greifen, weil wir haben eine andere Situation, wir haben eine andere Situation mit den Impfungen und mit den Varianten, die bisschen gegenläufig äh sind. Nur um jetzt mal so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen
von was für Inzidenzen wir sprechen, ne? Und natürlich ist die Verteilung in den Altersgruppen, da wirst du ja wahrscheinlich gleich noch was dazu sagen,
sicherlich auch eine ganz andere, aber so dass es äh in etwa der Punkt, den wir hatten, also drei Wochen vor dem zweiten Lockdown, das ist sozusagen gerade Inzidenz und zu dem Zeitpunkt war, glaube ich, die.
Beschlussfassung auch in etwa so Mitte Mitte Oktober, Mitte Ende Oktober war dann so der.
Haben sich dann endlich mal zusammengesessen und alle haben schon so geahnt, so okay, alles klar, jetzt ist bald vorbei.
Also kann sagen, wir sind bei der Inzidenz nicht so weit runtergekommen,
wie im letzten Jahr und äh haben halt statt mehrere wie im letzten Jahr mehrere Monate äh einfach äh ja einstellig.
Zu bleiben äh so ähm hat sich das gleich nach ein paar Wochen äh wieder gedreht.
Das Ganze, ja.
Stimmt. Im Prinzip so der der Einstieg, also dieses Tal, was sich da jetzt bildet, das was wir jetzt sozusagen gehabt haben.
Anfang Juni bis jetzt. Äh auf das letzte Jahr übertragen, wäre der Zeitraum von April bis Oktober.
Ne, also die Wanne, die sich da, die Inzidenzwanne, die sich da gebildet hat, äh die äh hat da sechs Monate gehalten und hier hat sie gerade mal zwei Monate gehalten.
Wenn das nicht gut.
Das ist nicht gut.
Auf der anderen Seite natürlich ähm.
Ist der entscheidende Unterschied äh vielleicht zum zum Positiven hin. Hm.
Ja, natürlich die Zahl äh der Todesfälle. Äh gut, die war im,
Jahr auch äh äh sehr, sehr niedrig ähm so, aber was man halt feststellen kann, ist und das ist vielleicht die entscheidende,
Erkenntnis oder einer der wichtigsten Nachrichten für mich, dass.
Sagen die äh Fallsterblichkeit ähm,
durch die Impfungen auf ein Zehntel äh rund von dem gefallen ist, was wir ja bisher so äh also vor den Impfungen beobachten konnten,
in der Pandemie. Also wir sind jetzt von, ich sage mal, rund drei Prozent,
Fallsterblichkeit im Schnitt, die wir so hatten vor den Impfungen, sind wir jetzt unter null Komma drei äh Prozent.
Runter und das ist im Moment der Kernunterschied.
Und äh ja, der, der natürlich auch die Reaktion äh jetzt beeinflussen,
weil das natürlich auch dafür steht, äh dass es deutlich,
weniger schwere Verläufe gibt und das eben wir auch sozusagen in dem Sinne die Inzidenz äh auch relativieren,
äh äh müssen oder können, so. Was aber äh auch bedeutet, also wenn wir jetzt sagen, okay.
Ähm da haben wir jetzt mit den Impfungen ist alles nur noch ein Zehntel so schlimm, wie es äh wie es vorher war
im Schnitt. Das heißt, wir können eine zehnmal so hohe hohe Inzidenzollerieren.
Ja, könnte man jetzt sagen, bevor das Gesundheitssystem überlastet ist so grob.
Einen Daumen so. Aber bei einem exponentiellen Anstieg ähm so, je nach je nach R-Wert ist halt ein Faktor von zehn dann auch ganz schnell erreicht,
ja? Ähm.
So und das ist äh so ein bisschen das Problem. Es gibt uns, also dieser Faktor zehn gibt uns halt jetzt ein bisschen mehr sage mal Sicherheit oder oder.
Puffer, was was die Überlastung des Gesundheitssystems angeht, aber eben halt nur ein bis zwei Monate. Ja,
je nach je nach Verdoppelungsrate ähm kann man kann man sagen und.
Vermutlich muss man auch davon ausgehen, dass so ungefähr die Hälfte der Bevölkerung im Moment noch grundsätzlich in Frage kommt als Wirt für das Virus im Moment und das.
Sind natürlich verdammt viele Leute, also im Prinzip können sich noch bis zu vierzig Millionen infizieren, würde ich sagen, oder ist es sehr wahrscheinlich, dass wenn man jetzt nicht weiter impft,
dass äh ja.
Sich fast alle von den vierzig Millionen äh wahrscheinlich dreißig oder fünfunddreißig Millionen muss man von ausgehen, wenn sich dann früher oder später infizieren. Wenn das über viele Jahre verteilt
ist, ist das jetzt nicht so das Problem, aber wenn die jetzt alle plötzlich sich in innerhalb von drei Monaten äh infizieren, dann äh
ist halt auch äh unser Gesundheitssystem äh dem nicht gewachsen. Ne, das ist die Situation, in der wir uns im Moment
befinden, so wie ich das einschätze.
Mhm. Aber das ist ein bisschen weniger. Wir haben jetzt äh knapp fünfundfünfzig Prozent der Bevölkerung vollständig geimpft.
Ja
Aber in Größenordnung hast du natürlich.
Mhm und ich gehe davon aus, äh dass eben auch ein Teil äh der
geimpften
entweder im Versager sind oder dass die Impfung schon äh lange äh zurückliegt, sodass sie nicht die nötigen Antikörper, die da haben und dass ein paar Prozent der Geimpften
auch in Frage kommen speziell äh für manche Varianten als Wirt. Deswegen habe ich halt nicht die Impfquote genommen, sondern ein bisschen abgezogen.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Genau. Mhm. Genau. Die Impfstoffe wirken ja auch nicht zu hundert Prozent. Also, äh ist ja auch klar. Mhm.
Ja. So, also ich habe sozusagen dann einfach mal zehn Prozent ähm Impfdurch.
Aber es ist ganz interessant. Ich äh blicke hier gerade auf deine äh Grafik. Die werden natürlich dann auch im im Blog haben,
und ähm Fallsterblichkeit für wenn die äh die Begrifflichkeit noch verwirrt. Ich habe auch, glaube ich, jetzt
anderthalb Jahre gebraucht, bis ich das irgendwie alles im Muscle Memory äh drin habe. Zählt also quasi,
Wie viel Leute, weil von wie viel Leuten weiß man, dass sie äh infiziert sind und wie viele sterben davon?
Ohne Dunkelziffer.
Dunkelziffer, genau und ähm drei Prozent ist eigentlich schon,
ziemliche Ansage so und das hast du jetzt quasi so gemittelt über die komplette Zeit und dem steht dann eben entgegen der äh Verlauf, der mehr oder weniger tagesaktuellen Fallsterbigkeit, ist natürlich nicht tagesaktuell, sondern,
dauert dann immer so zwei, drei Wochen, bis man aus der Zahl was rauslesen kann, aber die sinkt jetzt eben seit
der Hochphase der zweiten Welle mehr oder weniger kontinuierlich ab und lässt sich bisher auch noch nicht so richtig aus der Ruhe bringen.
Durch die äh steigende Inzidenz.
Also es ist immer noch rückläufig. Wenn die wieder ansteigen sollte, das wäre dann ein deutliches Warnsignal, dass wir es entweder dann mit Varianten zu tun haben, die,
die Impfung äh Immunität durchbrechen können oder wovon wir auch ausgehen müssen, dass zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt.
Nach sechs Monaten oder mehr hm die Antikörper-Tita, also die die.
Konzentration oder Anzahl neutralisierender Antikörper im Blut nimmt halt,
ab nach der zweiten Impfung. Die erreicht irgendwann gut nach der zweiten Impfung ein, zwei, drei Wochen danach erreicht die ihren Höhepunkt. Und danach äh sinkt sie halt.
Und äh die ist halt entscheidend, also die Neutralisierenden Antikörper sind halt entscheidend dafür, dass man sich gar nicht erst infiziert.
So, die anderen Antikörper, so T äh Gedächtniszellen, Bellen und so, die die bleiben, die halten länger und äh die sorgen dann eben äh dafür, dass wenn man sich ansteckt, der Verlauf halt
ein milderer äh ist, so also diese Schutzwirkung bleibt dann auf jeden Fall recht lange, aber was wir eben auch wissen, ist, dass es,
in geringer Zahl äh aber doch nennenswerter Zahl eben äh Leute gibt,
die vollgeimpft sind, die äh sich infizieren und auch das äh Virus an Infizierte weitergeben können. Das sind zwar, wie gesagt.
Ist nicht die Regel, ist sondern eher die Ausnahme, aber ist eben bei ein paar Prozent äh halt auch möglich. Und,
Ich meine, da werden wir dann auch später, glaube ich, noch etwas detaillierter drauf eingehen, so was es mit irgendwie dritter,
ähm,
Impfung äh jetzt für Leute zum Beispiel im Gesundheitswesen, die ganz am Anfang geimpft worden sind und für diejenigen, bei denen die letzte Dosis jetzt schon ein halbes Jahr zurückliegt oder so, ob man da was tun muss.
Impfung. Ja, da reden wir gleich noch drüber, bleiben wir erstmal bei den äh Zahlen. Also so viel zur äh Sterblichkeit. Da, das ist sozusagen jetzt erstmal der gute Nachrichtenteil gewesen.
Ja, ja. Ähm ja, mein Gut oder schlecht? Ähm.
Wenn wir dann jetzt mal,
weiterschauen, das ist ja auch immer interessant, was es mit den Altersgruppen, wie verteilen sich die Inzidenzen auf die Altersgruppen und entwickeln sich da und ja.
Da stellt man fest, dass die beiden Altersgruppen, also sechzig bis neunundsiebzig und achtzig Plus, die.
Sehr gut durchgeimpft sind, auch den niedrigsten Inzidenzwert haben, so zwischen fünf und sechs pro hunderttausend.
Und ja.
Und die vor allem bei der zweiten Welle halt ganz klar die am stärksten vertretene Gruppe waren, ne? Also als die
Welle kam und die Impfung noch nicht da war, war das ganz klar, dass eben die alten mit Abstand am stärksten betroffen sind
schon auch bei den Inzidenzen, bei der Sterblichkeit ja ohnehin. Und in der zweiten äh in der dritten Welle äh waren die auch noch irgendwie mit dabei und danach hat es dann doch stark äh.
Nachgelassen und dann sich getauscht. Ne, im Laufe des Sommers.
Ja und ähm die höchsten Inzidenzen mit mittlerweile.
Neunundvierzig, knapp fünfzig haben wir jetzt bei den fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig jährigen. So.
Und äh gefolgt dann mit einer Inzidenz von fünfunddreißig äh bei den.
Fünf bis Vierzehnjährigen, also bei den ja, Kindern eigentlich
und die Kleinkinder äh liegen immer noch unter den fünfunddreißig bis Neunundfünfzigjährigen bisher deutschlandweit, da sie null bis Vierjährigen haben eine Inzidenz von neunzehn Grad.
Wobei da.
Eben auch immer äh also die gerade die Inzidenzen bei Schülern und Kindern hm werden auch stark beeinflusst davon, ob jetzt grade Schule oder oder Kita,
ist und äh vor allem, wenn dort ein Testregime gefahren ist äh und die öffnen
ziehen die Zahlen dann besonders an, weil dann ja erstmal bei den Kindern ganz ganz viele Symptomlose sind, die dann erst überhaupt auffallen, dass sie infiziert sind. Deswegen
sagen, im Moment ja äh ist dort bei den Kindern vielleicht die Rate tatsächlich schon höher, aber es fällt halt nicht auf, weil die Symptome vielleicht nicht da sind.
Ich meine jetzt doppelt beunruhigend, dass jetzt ausgerechnet der.
Fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig und auch der Fünf- bis vierzehner Altersbereich so kontinuierlich hochschießt, weil wir hatten nun in den letzten Wochen überall Sommerferien.
Also.
Nicht gleichzeitig, ne? Ist ja alles verteilt, aber so in dem Blog vom also so Ende Juli, die letzte Juliwoche, da waren.
Stimmt auch nicht so ganz. Baden-Württemberg hat da gerade angefangen, also so ein bisschen Staffelübergabe. Sagen wir mal so, also die letzte
Juli und erster Augustwoche hat so die höchste Feriendichte insgesamt. Also es findet sehr wenig Schule statt. In Berlin geht's jetzt gerade erst wieder los. Mecklenburg und,
und äh Hamburg ein paar Tage früher schon so und Schleswig-Holstein, aber das war's dann halt auch.
Und Nordrhein-Westfalen und ähm Bayern jetzt auch Baden-Württemberg die ganzen Bevölkerungsreichen Länder, die haben halt jetzt Sommerferien. So, man würde ja meinen,
Ferienknick sehen könnte. Aber ich sehe da kein Ferienknick.
Nee, nicht so richtig, ist eher zu befürchten, äh dass jetzt durch die Ferien die Zahlen vielleicht noch äh noch.
Noch unten gehalten werden und dass wir dann.
Wenn denn dann äh ja die Schulen aufmachen und dort getestet wird, dass wir dann erstmal da in der Altersgruppe so einen richtigen Spike äh sehen werden.
Also Ende August.
Wobei eben auch ganz interessant ist, ich meine, das sind ja jetzt Inzidenzen.
Und wenn man äh sich das mal, was wir selten machen, aber einfach mal so nach
Alters äh äh Gruppen in absoluten Zahlen,
anschaut, wie viele Neuinfektionen das denn so sind und ich habe das hier mal für,
Tag äh so und zwar den ja fünften August, äh weil das ist einer, äh wo's eher mehr ist, wo es eher auf einem Wochenhoch ist und man das vielleicht besser vergleichen kann und.
Den ja äh Altersgruppe achtzig Plus äh sind's halt ja äh fünfundsechzig Neuinfektionen an dem Tag gewesen.
Bei den kleinen Kindern ungefähr, also bei dem bis.
Vierjährigen, einschließlich sind's hunderteinundzwanzig äh an dem Tag gewesen.
Dritthöchste ist dann sechzig bis neunundsiebzig, das waren hundertsechsundachtzig Neuinfektionen.
Bei den Schülern dann äh waren's an dem Tag dreihundertzweiundneunzig.
Und äh ja, in der Altersgruppe fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzig waren's dann tausendfünfunddreißig.
Und bei den fünfzehn bis vierunddreißigjährigen tausendsiebenhundertvierunddreißig. So.
Also in absoluten Zahlen sieht das Ganze dann nochmal äh.
Ja, wenn ich sagen bedrohlicher aus, aber macht halt klar, dass äh ja auf bestimmte Altersgruppen da grade ein Problem äh auf uns zukommt.
Also ich muss sagen, die Zahlen sind jetzt natürlich ein doppelter äh Schwurbleiben hören, weil wir haben's natürlich hier auch nicht mit homogenen ähm Jahresbereichen zu tun,
Ja, also die einen spannen zwanzig Jahre ab, die anderen äh,
Neun Jahre und andere Gruppe, also es ist halt irgendwie fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzig. Ich meine, das ist halt einfach fünfunddreißig, vierunddreißig Jahre, das ist irgendwie ein bisschen bisschen viel und dann äh das Ganze noch relativ zu der jeweiligen.
Ja
Kann ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt mit der absoluten Zahlen nicht so viel anfangen, was was willst du mir denn damit jetzt sagen?
Naja.
Wenn man sich jetzt anschaut zu sagen, wo dann welche Hospitalisierungen oder zu äh erwarten sind, also wenn man jetzt dann einfach guckt, okay, wie viele Leute in der Altersgruppe äh sind denn jetzt tatsächlich gerade.
Infiziert und da sieht man, dass eben zum einen in den Altersgruppen da überproportional viele Leute tatsächlich drin sind, aber auch nochmal überproportional viele
dann infiziert sind und das heißt eben nicht mehr und nicht weniger, dass eben jetzt bestimmte
Altersgruppen äh dort im Fokus stehen äh in absoluten Zahlen, was die Infizierten angeht.
Sondern auch die Krankenhausfälle. Hm.
Und die Krankenhaus äh äh Fälle so. Das ist äh halt der der Punkt, ja.
Großbritannien gab's ja mal so einen Tag, wo es keinen Toten gab. Das haben wir irgendwie jetzt gar nicht gesehen, oder?
Ne. Das hatten wir nicht meines Wissens, ne.
Na gut, so viel zu Altersverteilung.
Ja. Mhm.
Oder hast du noch mehr Altersverteilungen.
Äh ja, man könnte jetzt noch äh einen Blick sagen auf die.
Pseudo R Werte in den in den Altersgruppen werfen, wobei die.
Eher ich die eher unspektakulär fand, wobei äh ja,
dann doch sich die eben zwischen eins Komma null eins bei den älteren eins Komma null drei,
bis hin dann zu, ja, über eins Komma zwei.
Bei den, bei den Kindern äh gerade erstrecken. Also tatsächlich gerade sehen wir unter Kindern und Jugendlichen breitet es sich gerade am stärksten aus, aber es sind halt die Zahlen fluktuieren auch sehr, sehr stark äh muss.
Die Treiber der Pandemie, jetzt ham wir's.
Okay.
Ja und zwischenzeitlich hatten wir mal einen Riesenanstieg bei achtzig Plus für nur ein paar Tage bei den Infektionen. Unklar, was da passiert ist, äh so.
Ich sag mal siebenundzwanzigsten siebten bis sechsten achten oder so war plötzlich die Inzidenz bei über zwei, bei den über Achtzigjährigen,
aber ja, möchte irgendwelche statistischen Schwankungen unklar, wie es äh zu dem Ausreißer kommt, aber wie gesagt, sind auch wir haben's damit kleinen Basiszahlen zu tun,
was das Ganze natürlich, was das Rauschen auch entsprechend erhöht in den Zahlen. Ähm.
Ja, vielleicht noch dann einen Blick auf die Bundesländer, auf die Inzidenzunterschiede,
und ja da stellt man jetzt fest, dass irgendwie Thüringen äh gerade, lange Zeit so
eines der beiden mit Sachsen zusammen ja der der Inzidenz.
Spitzen, ja, Meister, Spitzenreiter, wie auch äh immer, äh ist gerade Tabellenschlusslicht ähm.
So mit sieben. Ja und.
Also Schlusslicht in den negativen Bewertungen, also eigentlich da sieht's am besten aus, sagen wir's mal so, ja. Niedrigste Inzidenz.
Wobei ich gerade gucke, wo ist denn da gerade Schleswig-Holstein? Ah.
Schleswig-Holstein ist auf Platz zwei, ja? Da ist es das.
War lange Zeit eher irgendwie eines der wiederum Paradiese der Glückseligen und äh ja.
Hamburg ist ganz weit vorne, ja.
Leider ganz schön angezogen. Ja und Hamburg ist ganz oben mit mit über fünfzig. Jetzt also Hamburg äh ja.
Ja. Weißt du eigentlich, wie das so ist, wenn ähm wenn jetzt ein Tourist.
Positiv gemeldet wird und also, sagen wir mal, jetzt fährt jemand von Bayern nach Schleswig-Holstein, macht da Urlaub und wird dort infiziert und wird dort auch getestet.
Fließt das dann in die Statistik von Schleswig-Holstein ein oder fließt das dann in die Statistik von Bayern ein?
So wie ich das mir das bekannt
ist äh am Ende in die von Bayern, aber es kann halt zwischendurch sein, äh dass es irgendwo anders in der Statistik auftaucht und es kann dann sein, dass der Fall dann quasi hinterher verschoben wird.
Mhm. Im Rahmen dieser ganzen permanent stattfindenden Korrekturen.
Genau, äh das ist sozusagen eine potenzielle Ursache für die Negativzahlen, die wir dann manchmal haben, weil äh sagen die erst ja.
Das heißt, die Inzidenz, die wir jetzt hier sehen von Schleswig-Holstein mit zweiundvierzig Komma fünf, kann nicht komplett jetzt durch touristische Aktivität erklärt werden.
Ja, also ich meine, irgendjemand muss das Virus natürlich schon da rein.
Aktivität kann dazu führen, aber ich meine, es muss jetzt äh es ist nicht, dass nur die Touristen sozusagen das jetzt hoch, weil jetzt alle irgendwie da sind, ja, sondern ähm.
Ist schon irgendwie in der in der eigentlich dort wohnenden Bevölkerung präsent.
Nee, definitiv.
Ja, also Hamburg liegt ganz vorne äh achtundfünfzig, reißt alles raus, Schleswig-Holstein, wie schon erwähnt, auf äh Platz zwei mit zweiundvierzig fünf, sieben, neununddreißig Komma äh acht schafft Berlin.
Auch alles schön steil nach oben gegangen, also die Städte überhaupt scheinen ähm.
Die Großen haben äh zugelegt.
Dann aber auch schon Nordrhein-Westfalen. Das zieht natürlich Deutschland insgesamt stark mit durch die vielen Leute, die da wohnen. Saarland, dann ist ein bisschen Pause und dann kommt irgendwie Bremen, Hessen, Rheinland-Pfalz, Niedersachsen, Baden-Württemberg.
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, Bayern, Brandenburg, Sachsen, Sachsen-Anhalt und wie schon erwähnt, Thüringen ganz am Ende dieser Liste.
Wir sind auch, ich habe gerade nochmal reingeguckt bei Schleswig-Holstein äh so, wo denn da ja,
wie sich denn da so die Fälle.
Verteilen und da kann man schon sagen, dass sie sich über fast alle Landkreise verteilen, also der niedrigste Landkreis hat einundzwanzig Komma vier und
das geht dann irgendwie bis vierundneunzig hoch in Neumünster und Flensburg ist auch mit irgendwie über siebzig und Kiel mit vierundsiebzig, also
ja Pinneberg, Lübeck, hm,
und ja, überall steigen die Zahlen und teilweise sind Plönen sogar äh ja, haben sie sich verzehnfacht, äh jetzt innerhalb von einer Woche,
also äh oder vor fünf, ja doch eine verzehnfacht von sieben auf siebzig. Ja.
Also das ist alles nicht so.
Gut, so viel zu den Bundesländern.
Noch einen anderen Betrachtungswinkel. Wir haben natürlich unsere positiv äh Quoten noch.
Ja und da stellt man fest, ja, dass die positiv.
Quote natürlich den Inzidenzen äh den steigenden Inzidenzen auch wieder folgt, wobei auch die Zahl der Tests äh deutlich,
genommen hat,
wir hatten so ein bisschen einen nicht den absoluten Höhepunkt, aber den also in diesem Jahr sagen der der Höhepunkt bei den Tests war so in der KW.
Sechzehn äh siebzehn, wo wir dann irgendwie eins Komma vier Millionen Tests hatten und ja, jetzt sind wir auf unter sechshunderttausend runter.
Und in,
Insofern äh ja äh ist halt äh gerade sagen wir der der Anstieg, also Anstieg, der positiv äh Quote bei,
fallen da bei einer fallenden Zahl von von Tests äh ja.
Äh ist nicht gut so. Äh also.
Natürlich auch das Verhalten an Lassen sich die Leute testen äh jetzt äh so könnte sich auch
verändert haben, wenn natürlich auch andere Altersgruppen und Symptomatik
und so sich verändert haben. Also, aber wir sehen halt jetzt seit eins, zwei, drei, vier Wochen in Folge eine steigende Positivquote und äh ja
das setzt sich leider fort und wir sind eben auch bei der positiven,
quote äh jetzt da, wo wir dann äh im Prinzip im September, Oktober letzten Jahres.
Anfang Oktober. Genau, also im Prinzip der Vergleich, den ich vorher mit der Inzidenz gemacht habe. Wir sehen bei der Positivquote genau dasselbe Bild. Und
das ist halt dann schon auch eben potenziell ein ein Trend und ja, das äh sieht jetzt gerade nicht so aus, als ob das schnell wieder runtergehen würde.
Also der, man könnte auch sagen, den Zahlennachricht, der Corona-Sommer jetzt vorbei.
Der Herbst hat der Corona-Herbst hat begonnen. Jetzt nach.
Zahlen. Äh äh Herbst ist dies Jahr etwas früher, ja. Äh und äh das alles nach Corona lauert dieses Jahr etwas länger. Ach ja.
Ja, genau.
Mhm. Ja, ich denke, so viel erstmal zu den Zahlen in Deutschland. Weiß nicht, wie viel Zeit wir jetzt mit dem Ausland äh noch verbringen äh wollen.
Man.
Vielleicht sollten wir erstmal äh die Impfkampagne in äh in Deutschland ein bisschen beleuchten. Ich glaube, das passt jetzt ganz gut äh zu den Zahlen.
Ja, seufz, kann ich dazu nur sagen. Also ich äh habe ja das hier alles so ein bisschen grafisch nachgeführt und
die Impfzahlen gehen einfach beständig nach unten. Das habe ich ja schon hier in der letzten Sendung vor einem Monat beklagt und seitdem hat sich einfach gar nichts verbessert, ganz im Gegenteil. Der der negative Trend,
fortgesetzt
und das bedeutet, dass wir jetzt ähm also eine permanente äh Verlangsamung haben, der
äh Gesamtzahl an äh Impfungen und dementsprechend gehen natürlich auch Erstimpfungen und Zweitimpfungen runter. Meine Erwartungen, die ich so im Juni noch,
habe, dass wir jetzt bald wieder mehr Erstimpfung sehen werden als Zweitimpfung hat sich genau überhaupt nicht bestätigt, ganz im Gegenteil. Die erste Impfungen fallen einfach enorm ab und das wäre also überhaupt noch auf äh ungefähr dreihundertfünfzigtausend Impfungen pro Tag äh kommen, liegt im wesentlichen noch an den durchzuführenden Zweitimpfung.
Die Erstimpfung tragen da grade mal mit sechzigtausend pro Tag im sieben Tages Schnitt äh bei,
Ob sich das nochmal ändern wird, können wir gleich nochmal drüber sprechen. Bleiben wir vielleicht einmal bei den Zahlen.
Stand heute haben wir zweiundsechzig Komma vier vier Prozent der Bevölkerung mit einer Erstimpfung, also einer Mindest äh Impfung.
Vollständig geimpft sind äh vierundfünfzig Komma acht zwo. Ne, also mal grob gesagt dreiundsechzig Prozent erstgeimpft äh knapp fünfundfünfzig Prozent vollständig geimpft, Stand heute.
Ähm ein bisschen in Relation setzen, möchte ich das aber noch, weil wir haben ja derzeit das Regime, das ich dass ich nur.
Zwölfjährige und älter offiziell impfen lassen können. Das mag er
einzelnen Ausnahmen geben, aber nicht viele, zumindest keine, die jetzt groß ins Gewicht fallen. Wenn ich das jetzt auf den Bevölkerungsanteil von zwölf Plus umrechne, haben wir jetzt siebzig Prozent Erstimpfung und ähm ja, einundsechzig
paar zerquetschte äh Prozent. Ähm vollständige Impfung. Also sechzig Prozent,
der Leute, die sich hätten impfen lassen können, die äh sind jetzt auch geimpft worden
ich hab's jetzt nicht hier mir nochmal rausgelegt, aber ich glaube, die Nachfrage bei Kindern bei zwölf plus ist durchaus hoch, also da sind jetzt schon so fünf Prozent
vollständig geimpft und äh ich glaube
zehn Prozent überhaupt geimpft, wenn ich's jetzt richtig in Erinnerung habe, vielleicht lag's sogar schon ein bisschen höher. Also die Nachfrage ist da. Und erst vor kurzem hat ja die Bundesregierung sich so ein bisschen an das Sticko vorbei
dazu entschlossen, jetzt einfach ein ganz klares Impfangebot zu machen. Also wir hatten das jetzt hier als Feedback auch auf die Sendung oft gehört
wo wir immer gesagt haben, so hier schickt doch bitte eure Kinder auch zur Impfung.
Dass dann viele gesagt haben, ja, uns, uns impft einfach keiner. Ja, die Impfzentren machen's generell nicht, in Hamburg irgendwie ab achtzehn plus und äh Ärzte haben's abgelehnt. Alle haben auf die Stiko äh verwiesen oder
Aus anderen Gründen, das ist nicht gemacht. Also viele hatten da an der Stelle auch nicht die Möglichkeit. Ist jetzt so ein bisschen meine Hoffnung, dass wir zumindest in diesem Bereich ähm
von den Impfwilligen nochmal so einen gewissen Buß bekommen. Der wird jetzt hier durch den den gesamten Trend wieder nach oben schieben, aber vielleicht ein bisschen
auffangen, also die derzeit sinkenden Kurven haben
etwas aufgehört so stark zu sinken, ist eine leichte Abflachung, aber noch nichts, was mich so stimmen würde, dass ich sagen kann, wir haben jetzt hier eine eine Trendwende bei den Impfungen, da sind wir noch weit von entfernt.
Und wir sind jetzt auch schon so an dem Punkt angekommen, wo die Bundesländer sagen, wir haben jetzt mehr Impfstoffe als wir brauchen und wir geben die jetzt wieder ab.
Ne, also ist da in größerem Maße schon äh rausgeschickt worden, aber eben auch andere Impfstoffe, ja,
drohen halt abzulaufen und man sieht einfach an den Zahlen, dass das, was jetzt eben vorrätig ist, nicht aufgebraucht wird und dann wird es halt dann doch äh eher in andere Länder verschenkt,
Wo ich jetzt auch nichts dagegen habe,
sagen muss, naja, gut, also wenn wir es nicht verimpft bekommen, dann klar, dann soll es natürlich so schnell wie möglich äh woanders zum Einsatz kommen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, mich macht das irgendwie immer noch so ein bisschen fassungslos. Also ich habe einfach gedacht, dass wir locker ähm noch zehn Prozent mehr erreichen, bevor wir ähm so eine abfallende Zahl sehen und nicht.
Mich mich ärgert das so ein bisschen. Ich würde nicht von frustrierend sprechen. Man man kann sich das natürlich jetzt auch schönreden und sagen, na ja, siebzig Prozent, sieben von zehn
denen, die äh denen es möglich war, die haben's schon gemacht. Das ist jetzt auch nicht nichts, wenn man jetzt mal von.
Eigentlich sogar schon sagen, ganz gut, zumal ja bei den, ich sage mal, zwölf Plus. Ähm wie gesagt, die Stiko.
Ja auch das nicht empfohlen hat und das den Leuten echt schwer gemacht äh wurde, also vor dem Hintergrund würde ich sagen, sind die siebzig Prozent äh.
Eigentlich,
'nen OK Wert, ja? Eigentlich möchte man natürlich am Ende irgendwo deutlich über neunzig Prozent liegen.
So, aber äh ja.
Möchte man, ne? Also.
Hätten wir jetzt quasi so von äh von den Ältesten zu den Jüngsten durchgeimpft so, also äh das, was jetzt äh erst verimpft ist, entspricht so ungefähr der dem Bevölkerungsteil fünfunddreißig Plus.
Also es ist so achtundneunzig Komma sechs Prozent von fünfunddreißig plus. Die sind ähm.
Dass so die Menge an Menschen, die das jetzt äh erreicht hat, ne. Natürlich sind nicht alle.
Bereich fünfunddreißig plus äh geimpft. Naja und äh vollständig geimpft sind so sechsundachtzig. Aber.
Trotzdem, also ich, ich will da noch mehr sehen und vor allem die niedrigen Erstimpfungen, ja, das das äh bedeutet, dass es halt einfach alles noch eine Weile dauern wird. So, ja klar, es gibt Jansen und Jansen.
Oder Johnson und Johnson, den Jansen äh äh Impfstoff, wo man nur äh einen braucht und dann ist man hier auch in der Vollständig geimpft Kategorie. Aber
Na ja, also ist es ähm es ist so, es ist so, wie es ist, ne. Dazu kommt noch, dass eben mir viele Impfzentren jetzt Ende August schließen werden, hier unter anderem die Arena, aber auch noch ein paar andere Impfzentren, manche haben auch schon zugemacht,
Äh das wird sich also dann alles in zunehmendem Maße auf die Praxen verlagern. Ähm derzeit ähm.
Gucke grad noch mal, wie sich das derzeit verteilt, derzeit hält sich das noch die Waage. Also derzeit sind wirklich alle Impfungen ungefähr gleich verteilt zwischen Praxen und Impfzentren etwas mehr bei den Praxen.
Und äh demnächst stehen ja dann auch noch dritte Impfungen an. Die sind ja jetzt auch beschlossen worden, das heißt ältere Leute und Risikofälle äh kriegen das Angebot einer dritten Impfung und sollten die natürlich auf jeden Fall wahrnehmen
denn äh hattest du das gesagt, dass so das Risiko von jemand, der.
Ähm Geimpftes in der achtzig Plus-Kategorie ungefähr dem Risiko, dem Sterberrisiko entspricht von Ungeimpften Fünfzigjährigen. War das deine Rechnung?
Das woanders aufgeschnappt.
Das hast du wahrscheinlich woanders, aber äh nee, könnte aber ja, kann ungefähr hinkommen, ja.
Ja und man merkt halt bei Älteren jetzt bei Testers da einfach die Antikörper schneller äh fallen. Das ist ja auch normal, weil einfach, ne, umso älter man ist.
Beziehungsweise Gabsuntersuchung eben ja auch.
Zitiert, wo eben bis zu ein Drittel äh der über siebzigjährigen äh keine neutralisierenden Antikörper entwickelt äh haben.
Ähm das war jetzt nur eine eine, aber man kann davon ausgehen, dass zumindest weiß man äh je älter eine Gruppe typischerweise ist, umso,
weniger ausgeprägt im Durchschnitt ist die Immunantwort äh und umso weniger äh ja
ähm ja neutralisierende Antikörper vor allem äh werden dann äh produziert.
Und äh ja und dasselbe gilt dann wahrscheinlich auch für bestimmte Risikopatienten, die äh deren Immunsystem nicht in Ordnung ist.
Hat äh auch explizit eine dritte Dosis ähm streben sie schon an. Es gibt da äh schon entsprechende Untersuchungen, nach denen eine dritte ein dritter Schott mit dem bereits existierenden Impfstoff
Ja, also mit dem, was jetzt auch schon vorrätig ist, äh nach sechs bis zwölf Monaten ähm
Ihrer Meinung nach äh irgendwann erforderlich sein wird und Sie haben da eine Studie laufen und die ersten Daten dieser Studie
zeigen angeblich, dass die Menge an Antikörper noch mal durch die dritte Impfung um das fünf bis Zehnfache erhöht wird,
Und da wollen sie demnächst auch ein entsprechendes Paper veröffentlichen, das äh.
Ich nicht, das ist jetzt tatsächlich noch eine relativ alte Meldung, die ich jetzt hier habe. Da muss ich gerade nochmal gucken, ob das eigentlich mittlerweile schon veröffentlicht wurde, weil das ist jetzt eine Meldung aus dem Juli.
Ähm ja und.
Sie wollen auch einen an Delta angepassten Impfstoff natürlich auch noch entwickeln, aber der müsste, wenn ich das richtig sehe, auch noch mal abgesegnet werden
von der IMA und ähm auch wenn das dann natürlich nicht so lange dauern wird, weil darüber hatten wir ja nun schon tausendmal gesprochen. Großer Vorteil von diesen MRNA Impfstoffen ist, dass die eigentliche Rezeptur,
ja gar nicht so sehr das Problem ist, sondern eben die Gesamtwirkung und die ändert sich ja äh nicht nennenswert dadurch, dass jetzt äh Anpassung ans Virus vorgenommen werden. Also klar muss man sich ja auch.
Et cetera, da stecke ich jetzt im einzelnen nicht so äh drin, aber man kann davon ausgehen, dass das eben jetzt nicht nur mal ein halbes Jahr dauert, um das irgendwie abzusegnen.
Ja und insgesamt zeigte sich halt aber auch, dass der bestehende MRNA Impfstoff
wohl
gegen die meisten Varianten dann doch noch ganz gut hilft. Aber
ja aus Israel teilweise gab's dann eben auch so ein paar Nachrichten
die dann so interpretiert wurden, dass es irgendwie überhaupt nicht hilft oder dass dort mittlerweile ja was in,
geimpft Durchbrüche in größerem Umfang stattfinden. Ähm ich habe da jetzt.
Eher äh also,
anekdotisch äh vor allem äh gehört. Ich aber noch keine ähm brauchbaren Studien gefunden, die das jetzt untermauern. Hast du da was äh von gehört?
Also, ja, kommen wir mal so ein bisschen auf die Wirkung äh zu Delta. Also ich habe da einiges gehört, denn ich habe ja auch einiges äh gesammelt und irgendwie widersp
ich würde nicht sagen, es widerspricht sich, aber es ist ähm noch kein klares Gesamtbild
Also ähm in schon im Juni gab's in England die Meldung, dass sowohl äh Pfizer als auch,
nach zwei äh Shots nach wie vor sehr wirksam ist gegen Delta.
Ja? Ähm in Israel und auch in Island gab es ja auf einmal extrem steigende,
ähm Inzidenzen, nur so wie ich das mitbekommen habe, ähm,
genauer habe ich hier einen Link auf eine Analyse aus Island, ja, wo man dreiundneunzig Prozent.
Mit von sechzehn plus geimpft sind
trotzdem auf einmal ähm eine starke Inzidenzwelle äh kam, aber wenn man sich das halt anschaut, dann ist halt tatsächlich die Inzidenz wirklich bei den
jungen Leuten dann eben ganz stark die eben noch nicht geimpft sind
So und da steigen dann die Inzidenzen wiederum so stark, dass es dann eben insgesamt so weit nach oben schießt.
Und das äh ist soweit ich das jetzt äh rausgelesen habe, auch in Israel nicht so sehr viel äh anders.
Nur nur Delta, und das hast du ja vorhin schon angedeutet, kann eben auch bei Geimpften zu einer Infektion führen,
Es führt nicht zu einer Hospitalisierung so oft und es führt schon gar nicht zu Todesfällen so oft. Also die Impfstoffe tun eigentlich genau das, was sie sagen.
Sie verhindern schwere Fälle und damit verhindern sie Todesraten, hohe Todesraten oder überhaupt Todesfälle. Und ähm,
dass Leute, die wirklich vollständig geimpft sind, trotzdem sich infizieren und dann auch noch daran sterben, dass es wirklich super selten.
Überall. Und ähm deswegen macht es einfach nach wie vor
total Sinn, sich äh impfen zu lassen, ist einfach nach wie vor der einzige wirkliche äh nennenswerte Schutz davor, in irgendeiner Form
Schaden zu nehmen. Es bewahrt einen vor Tod, es bewahrt euch vor äh schweren Verläufen und vor allem der äh heimlichen Bedrohung äh,
ja, das ist kein Spaß, also Freundin von mir, die betrifft das auch. Ja, die hat im Dezember sich das Virus äh eingefangen und die hat jetzt auch acht Monate danach.
Immer noch absolut krasse Einschränkungen. Nicht belastbar, ja, mental ist auch einfach.
Es geht auf alles, ja? Es geht auf die Kondition, es geht auf die den gesamten Körper äh Zustand, es geht auf die Konzentration.
Und auch eine Impfung,
hat leider nicht oder zumindest noch nicht zu einer Verbesserung oder einem dauerhaften Verbesserung und nachhaltigen Verbesserungen des Zustands gebracht und und das ist auch, glaube ich, das, was jetzt,
ein bisschen droht in dieser ganzen Debatte mit, wir sterben ja nicht mehr so viele. Ja, so was wie Loncovid, das wird dann halt irgendwie nicht so richtig gesehen. Naja, ich will jetzt nicht äh groß ähm.
Von Delta äh ablenken. Tatsache ist.
Die Impfstoffe helfen nach wie vor, aber sie verhindern gerade eben nicht diese Inzidenzausbrüche, was einfach damit zu tun hat, dass diese Deltavariante einfach einen extrem,
hohen R0-Wert zu haben scheint, also du hast ja die Zahlen dir glaube ich auch mal angeschaut,
Ich habe irgendwas gehört um die acht, ja? Also zur Erinnerung, das ursprüngliche Coronavirus saß zwei Corona-Virus, ist glaube ich mit drei Komma fünf äh gestartet, ne?
R-Wert, wenn man nichts dagegen tut in der Bevölkerung, ne? Und äh jetzt sind wir halt äh mit dieser Deltavariante schon bei acht bis
bis bis zehn, je nachdem, wo man so liest, wenn man eben nichts dagegen tut und ja gut, die Impfstoffe, die tun halt was dagegen, aber die können eben diese.
Krassen Druck, diesen hohen Infektionsdruck, der dadurch erzeugt wird, eben auch nur begrenzt aufnehmen.
Ja, ich habe sogar äh Zahlen äh von bis zu zehn äh gehört. Ähm aber auf jeden Fall, ja,
ich sag mal deutlich über den fünf oder sechs, den man für die britische Variante, war das jetzt bitter oder Alpha.
Die britische war Alpha.
Alfi, ja. Äh so, weil die ist eh jetzt schon wieder ist jetzt schon wieder fast vergessen. Die ist fast ja fast schon ausgestorben.
Ja, das war früher.
Damals.
Vor einem halben Jahr, hm.
Ja
Ähm gut aus, hier, wie gesagt, vorhin schon mal gesagt, was wir in den Zahlen jetzt real.
Deutschland sehen ist, dass.
Sehr wahrscheinlich oder eigentlich nur äh kann's nur an der Impfung äh liegen oder fast nur an der Impfung liegen ist, dass ähm.
Wir äh ja, dass die Sterblichkeit eben äh um den Faktor zehn äh gesunken ist. Derjenigen, die sich äh infizieren,
beziehungsweise natürlich hat das auch was damit zu tun, dass die Inzidenzen in den hohen Altersgruppen jetzt so niedrig sind das führt natürlich das denkt natürlich.
Insgesamt äh auch die Zahlen, aber das ist natürlich den Impfstoffen zu verdanken. Also es ist sozusagen ja, die.
Die Wirkung der Impfstoffe in ihrer Summe äh im Moment äh führt dazu, äh gerade, dass nur ein Zehntel der Leute äh sterben, äh die sich infizieren wie vor, sagen wir mal, einem Jahr oder so.
Oder wie vor einem halben Jahr auf dem äh ja Höhepunkt der zweiten Bälle.
Und und das vor dem Hintergrund, dass wir halt eine hohe äh äh Delta ähm.
Einen extrem hohen Delta-Anteil haben äh gerade, das heißt äh sagen die Impfstoffe beziehen das eben auch einer dieser Faktor zehn äh bezieht das eben auch ein. Und
man kann wahrscheinlich auch sagen, dass wenn wir tatsächlich die gesamte Bevölkerung so durch,
impfen könnten, wie die höheren Altersgruppen, dann hätten wir Ruhe,
ja, dann hätten wir immer noch einstellige Inzidenzen äh in der äh gesamten Bevölkerung und so gut wie keinen Anstieg.
Schön wär's. Dann hoffen wir mal, äh dass auch die Jüngeren demnächst besseren Zugang zu den Impfungen erhalten. Da laufen ja die Studien, aber die Dauer natürlich eine Weile. Wobei das könnte sich natürlich jetzt durch Delta auch wieder beschleunigen.
Ja ähm Varianten, also äh derzeit ist
All Hands on Deck in Bezug auf Delta. Europa ist halt einfach fest im Griff von Delta, so auch Asien, auch andere Länder haben da so ihre Probleme selbst äh Länder, die bisher relativ äh erfolgreich.
Ähm die ganze Pandemie im Griff gehalten haben. Taiwan, Thailand, äh,
glaube ich. Jetzt komme ich gerade ein bisschen durcheinander, aber auch China haben jetzt alle äh mit Ausbrüchen zu kämpfen.
Haben natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen das Problem, dass sie dadurch, dass sie relativ erfolgreich mit ihrer No-Covic-Strategie waren.
Dass sie wiederum sich beim Impfen nicht so.
Angeschränkt haben. Und jetzt trifft natürlich Delta auf die Länder mit so einem R von acht und dann funktioniert natürlich auch die Maßnahmen auf einmal nicht mehr sehr sehr gut,
dem Moment, wo man's einmal im Land hat und nicht äh sofort wieder rausgeschüttelt bekommt, wird's äh haarig.
Ich würde meinen, so einen Blick auf die anderen Länder, sollten wir vielleicht mal so in den nächsten Sendungen wieder einfließen lassen, weil da habe ich mich jetzt nicht so richtig schlau gemacht, wie es da jetzt gerade aussieht.
Würde jetzt nochmal kurz bei den Varianten bleiben und was so bei den Impfstoffen so generell eigentlich noch Neues ist. Gibt ja auch noch Lamm da,
ja, mit Lamm, da haben wir irgendwie ähm noch nicht so viel Kontakt geschlossen. Das ist halt so mehr, dass südamerikanische Geschehen, ne, also in äh Südamerika grassierte ja äh.
Jetzt nicht durcheinanderkommen, also Beta war ja dann die südafrikanische äh Variante und die brasilianische P1, das ist Gaming
mich jetzt nicht täusche. Und ähm mittlerweile gab's aber auch dort,
weitere Mutationen und Südamerika ist jetzt so ein bisschen im Griff von Lammda. Und Lambda ist wieder mal eine andere Mischung. Man ist sich derzeit noch nicht so ganz so sicher. Inwiefern die Impfstoffe dagegen äh halten,
Da allerdings in Südamerika halt viel mit chinesischen Impfstoffen geimpft wurde, äh wo auch schon der Erfolg gegen äh Alpha und Delta äh wohl nicht so gut aussah oder gar nicht weiß, die Delta hatten die, glaube ich, nicht, aber zumindest die anderen ähm
Impfstoffe konnten generell nicht die Inzidenzen so in den Griff halten, wie man sich das vielleicht äh erhofft hat.
Ähm ja, äh bereitet sich jetzt diese Lammdariante aus, die aber meines Wissens bisher in Europa noch keine Rolle spielt, aber das kann natürlich auch nochmal äh.
Bedeuten, dass die irgendwie auch noch kommt.
Johnson und Johnston, der Impfstoff, den wir ja auch noch haben, der äh ja, die meinen, dass sie, also der.
Das Unternehmen Johnson und Johnson meint, dass ihr Jansen Impfstoff, so heißt er ja eigentlich,
schnell ins Schleudern hier äh nach wie vor gut hält, auch gegen,
Delta auch langfristig äh hält und dass sie da keinerlei Auffrischung derzeit äh nötig halten,
ganz gute Nachrichten. Ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen mit Vorsicht zu genießen, wenn man sich jetzt hier auf die offiziellen Verlautbarungen,
der äh Unternehmen selbst äh verlässt, aber ich meine, immerhin sagen sie einem nicht, dass wir was Neues kaufen sollen, ist ja auch ganz gut, ne.
Chinesischen Impfstoffe, wie gesagt, nicht so erfolgreich. Ähm die
China will hat jetzt auch einen Deal mit Biontech gemacht, das heißt, sie werden jetzt auch eine Produktionsanlage in äh China am Start bringen oder sind schon dabei, das an äh Start zu bringen
und ähm wollen halt jetzt ihre Bevölkerung auch mit Biotech versorgen. Das ist natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht ein
ein Misserfolg der eigenen Impfstoffentwicklung. Ich meine, es ist schon gelungen, einen Impfstoff zu machen, aber die die Effektivität war halt auf der einen Seite sowieso schon nicht so hoch und die Varianten machen den chinesischen Impfstoffen jetzt nochmal richtig zu schaffen.
Ganz so aus als ob äh im RNA, Impfstoffe am Ende wirklich das sind, was sie jetzt hier am meisten Fortschritte erzeugt.
Äh es gab ja auch wieder einen Ausbruch in äh Wuhan
ähm ist jetzt schon wieder ein, zwei Wochen her die Meldung, was jetzt nicht ganz genau, wie es weitergegangen ist. Äh die sind ja dann immer relativ äh krass unterwegs, ne. Also es gab da irgendwie dreihundert Infektionen
und äh schon wird einfach mal die ganze Stadt durchgetestet. Das können sie, die Chinesen.
Ja und bei moderner gibt's nicht so richtig viele News, außer dass ähm.
Der Impfstoff jetzt auch für äh Jugendliche zwölf plus freigegeben ist, also genauso wie Biontech, also auch an der Stelle gibt's überhaupt gar keinen ähm keinen Mangel, also es gibt einfach genug Impfstoffe auch für Jugendliche.
Ähm ja. Geht alle impfen und nimmt eure Kinder mit. Und Kuba hat noch einen eigenen Impfstoff entwickelt. Äh.
Ja. Ich konnte aber wenig Informationen irgendwie wenig Konkretes dazufinden auf Anhieb.
Was das denn für eine Technologie ist und äh was der denn ja außer irgendwie dieser Effizienzwert da für den einen Impfstoff, weißt du da Näheres? Ähm.
Na ja, also sie behaupten, es sind alles Behauptungen, ne, dass sie äh irgendwie auf zweiundneunzig Prozent Effektivität kommen, allerdings mit drei äh Dosen. Also es äh sind drei Impfungen, die irgendwie äh erforderlich sein sollen,
Ähm ja, das ist äh das ist ein Protein-Impfstoff. Also so ähnlich wie dieser Nova-Wachs äh ganz äh.
Klassisches, aber fast sagen, Modell, also hier wird nicht der Körper.
Durch RNA oder DNA äh durch äh Botenstoffe oder durch einen Vektorvirus instruiert, das Protein, das äh Antikörper.
Auslösende Protein zu äh erzeugen und dann setzte Immun,
das Immunsystem an, sondern hier werden halt wie bei Novax äh direkt dieses Spike Proteine oder zumindest die so ähnlich aussehen in den Körper gespritzt und entwickeln da ihre Wirkung. Aber es ist halt alles nur in Kuba zugelassen und ähm,
muss man sehen, ob sie damit Erfolg haben. Also dazu muss man natürlich auch sagen, Kubas.
Kuba hat viele Probleme und Kuba hat vieles nicht, aber wenn sie irgendwo wirklich exzellent sind dann in der Medizin. Also das der medizinische Bereich in Kuba ist einer der besten ähm zumindest ähm.
Nein, nein, aber das.
Äh nein äh auch durchaus den gewissen Eindruck vor Ort hattest von dem Land.
Ja genau und das das hilft einem ja immer dabei so so Nachrichten äh zu absorbieren. Also wenn man irgendwie erstmal irgendwo gewesen ist, ne, dann dann kann man das äh dann ist man da irgendwie empfänglicher dafür. Und so habe ich das eigentlich auch immer so ein bisschen verfolgt, so ausm Augenwinkel ist jetzt schon wirklich
sehr lange her, dass ich da war. Beeindruckendes Land, viele Probleme natürlich, aber äh die sind halt im Bereich ähm,
Also im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern in Mittel-und Südamerika sind sie äh schon immer viel besser gewesen, was so Lesen und Schreiben der Bevölkerung betrifft. So, da sind sie irgendwie fast bei hundert Prozent
und äh die medizinische Versorgung, ne, also ich meine als als die USA da
Hurricane, äh Kathrina, Probleme äh hatten da irgendwie äh die Versorgung zu gewährleisten und
kam Kuba auch gleich an, hat gesagt so, ja, hier, kein Problem, wir haben ja ganz viele Ärzte, die können euch helfen, haben's natürlich nicht angenommen, weil ne, Ehre und so, aber.
Kuba ist gut aufgestellt und ich glaube, dass dass die jetzt sozusagen jetzt äh durchaus äh das seriös betreiben, dieses Impfstoffbusiness,
Impfstoff jetzt funktionieren wird und Erfolge erzielen wird, muss man schauen, aber ist halt auf jeden Fall so.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen das das Neues aus aus Impfhausen, ähm was ich jetzt hier so äh.
Zusammengefegt habe. Es tut sich da auf jeden Fall einiges und mal gucken, wie's weitergeht.
Ja und es ist ja der Schaden nicht, ne, der der Unternehmen. Also.
Nee, ich hatte mir äh mal die Bierentech-Quartalsergebnisse äh angeschaut. Ähm.
Das fand ich auch nochmal ganz interessant, darauf ist mir viel äh davon hatten wir, glaube ich, schon erwähnt, aber ich fand es sehr interessant, dass sie jetzt äh im ersten Halbjahr.
Bisher eine Milliarde Dosen ausgeliefert haben, also,
Ähm jetzt mittlerweile werden's ein bisschen mehr sein und habe auch Verträge für zwei Komma zwei Milliarden Dosen äh in zweitausendeinundzwanzig, also.
Prinzip sagen nochmal das Doppelte, was sie im ersten Halbjahr gemacht haben, wollen sie im zweiten Halbjahr machen.
Also insgesamt gehen sie von drei Milliarden Dosen äh bis Ende zweitausendeinundzwanzig aus, die sie
produziert, äh die sie in diesem Jahr produzieren und gehen davon aus, dass sie die Kapazität auf vier Milliarden Dosen für zwanzig zweiundzwanzig äh äh steigern,
werden, so das sind deren Planungen. Dann hat's ja schon erwähnt, ja auch, dass halt klinische Studien mit Kindern ab sechs Monaten laufen, also bis es sechs Monate bis elf Jahre,
und äh ja, dann auch schon erwähnt, äh dass dieser die Studie zur dritten Boosterdosis äh und so. Ähm,
Ja, dann aber auch noch in anderen äh Bereichen. Ganz interessant, dass sie jetzt grade die Entwicklung des eines Malaria-Impfstoffs angekündigt haben, dass,
beginnt aber erst, aber dafür in der Onkologie-Pipeline, also was
im RMA Impfstoffe zur Krebsbekämpfung äh angeht, haben sie, wo irgendwie gerade fünfzehn klinische Produktkandidaten, die sie in achtzehn laufen, in klinischen Studien äh untersuchen.
Und äh ja,
ist eigentlich äh interessante ist, sind natürlich in bei Quartalsergebnissen äh Quartalsberichten natürlich äh die Ergebnisse und
ja Umsätze
jetzt im zweiten Quartal haben sich gegenüber dem Vorjahr rund vor hundertfacht, also von neunundsechzig Komma vier Millionen auf sieben Komma drei sechs Milliarden.
Für die anderen Quartale sah das auch ungefähr so aus. Also äh ja,
dass kann man durchaus als Wachstum bezeichnen.
Ja, das kann man als Wachstum bezeichnen. Also wer da Aktien gekauft hat, der kann sich glücklich äh schätzen, weil die gehen äh ordentlich durch die durch die Decke.
Und äh was soll ich sagen? Mit Recht. Also äh ich äh.
Überhaupt gar kein äh Problem ist ja auch so so populär solchen Unternehmen dann den Erfolg nicht zu gönnen. Ich muss sagen, warum eigentlich nicht? Ist doch super.
Mal äh ordentlich Gewinn machen. Äh die haben so viel in der Pipeline, wenn wenn davon irgendwas äh auch noch funktioniert, dann dann ist das einfach gut für uns.
Also bin ich auf jeden Fall deutlich sympathischer als äh irgendwelche sozialen äh äh Netzwerke oder überhaupt äh ja.
Irgendwelche äh ja Internet putzen, äh die.
Alles nur schlimmer machen.
Dann äh ja als nicht unbedingt äh besser machen äh in der Welt,
und äh ja, eigentlich nur von letztlich Netzwerkeffekten
profitieren und nicht unbedingt jetzt von einer besonderen Exzellenz oder so, sondern eigentlich zur richtigen Zeit am richtigen Ort
waren und dann die ersten waren, die dann in der Regel gewachsen sind in dem Bereich, äh ja und.
Von daher, na ja.
Biotech ist natürlich jetzt der der Gewinner, ne, aber was, was ich natürlich hiermit auch äh abzeichnet und was sich in diesen äh Umsätzen teilweise eben auch mitzeigt,
Es ist halt diese MRNA Technologie, die die wirklich den Unterschied macht,
und äh man muss sich nur anschauen, was jetzt die großen Konzerne äh machen
Also ich glaube Sanofi, Frankreich, die haben sich jetzt irgendwie auch so eine amerikanische MRNA-Bude noch äh mit eingekauft, also alle,
bringen jetzt auf diesen Zug auf. Das ist äh wenig überraschend, weil es hat sich halt einfach jetzt gezeigt, dass das äh wunderbar funktioniert, ja gar nicht mal nur für Impfstoffe, sondern eben auch für generell für Medikamente aller Art
hatten wir glaube ich auch schon mal erwähnt, aber es gibt so die Schätzungen, dass wir so in ein paar Jahren äh auf so einen,
Markt von Medikamenten blicken werden, wo du dreißig Prozent aller auf dieser MRNA-Basis funktioniert. Das ist einfach sehr viele
Medikamentierung, wie man sie heute kennen durch eine komplett neue Technologie äh umgesetzt werden.
Muss ich natürlich jetzt noch zeigen, ob das jetzt dann wirklich auch in allen Bereichen so äh funktionieren wird, aber ich glaube, die Chancen dafür stehen jetzt mal gar nicht so schlecht und das ist natürlich auch das, was ich dann hier in äh Aktienkursen und äh am Ende natürlich auch in Gewinn niederschlägt.
Ja, was ich immer, was ich spannend,
finde auch an äh DMRNA Technologie ist, dass es ja letztlich wir jetzt äh in einen Informationskrieg
angetreten sind mit anderen Organismen, ja. Hm sprich letztlich,
was die was die Viren ja tun, ist, das sind ja auch eigentlich Informationspakete,
die in die Zelle eindringen mit einem Programm, mit einer Software und die Zelle kapern.
Und äh dann zum einen ja mit der Rechenleistung der Zelle,
die dazu nutzen so Zellen sind ja universelle Maschinen und auch universelle Maschinen.
Und äh ja, äh nutzt die Rechenleistung der Zelle, um äh dann Kopien äh von sich äh anzufertigen, aber auch,
letztlich um äh mit den Mutationen dann äh eine Suche äh also,
letztlich eine Art genetischen Algorithmus äh zu fahren, der halt sich auf die Suche macht nach besseren äh Varianten und auch eben neue Varianten hervorbringt und die eben auch ausprobiert. So,
und im Moment und das ist ja halt auch so ein bisschen das das Problem. Ich habe mir gerade nochmal angeguckt, wie denn die weltweiten Zahlen eigentlich aussehen und da sind wir weltweit eigentlich so in der vierten Welle äh drin, die jetzt der.
Ja die den letzten beiden,
Wellen ungefähr gleich kommt und so weltweit stecken sich
achthundert äh tausend Leute grade an pro Tag, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ja, ungefähr achthunderttausend, äh,
so, das heißt, äh dass wir ungefähr äh ja zehn Millionen Leute äh rumlaufen auf der Welt, in denen das Virus repliziert, mindestens, also
viele Millionen Leute und in denen halt Milliarden äh an äh Kopien
angefertigt werden, sondern sich dann überlegt, was das halt für eine gigantische Rechenleistung ist, die da gerade gegen uns eingesetzt wird
um bessere Varianten äh äh zu finden, ja, dann ist das nicht gut. Also eigentlich müssten wir dem Virus jetzt ein bisschen
mehr äh Rechenleistung klauen und letztlich ist dann die MRNA Technologie dann wieder, wo wir dann künstlich hergestellte Informationen, Programme
einschleusen, äh die dann äh ja unser Immunsystem eben programmieren,
um äh mit bestimmten Informationen, äh mit Steckbriefen, äh wie äh diese andere feindliche Information aussieht.
Wenn sie entpackt ist. Ähm ja,
und äh wir sind also und sagen jetzt in einem Informationskrieg ähm.
Eingetreten und äh mal sehen, wer gewinnt. Also ideal wäre es natürlich gesagt, wenn wir halt dem Virus ein bisschen mehr Rechenleistung äh.
Knappsen könnten und das beantwortet dann auch so ein bisschen die Frage mit den Varianten. Ähm ich meine, zum einen,
Könnte es sein, dass einmal die Theorie, dass sagen Virus, sondern bestimmten Suchraum.
So ein Raum an Varianten, was
entdecken äh kann, um ansteckender zu werden, also sagen
einen limitierten Satz an an Verbesserungsmöglichkeiten. Und dass der irgendwann erschöpft ist und äh ja, dann äh sagen ähm kann äh
der Virus keine neuen Varianten mehr oder keine besseren Varianten mehr finden. So, aber hm es gibt,
im Moment aus meiner Sicht keine Anhaltspunkte, dass äh ja, dass,
jetzt eingetreten ist, dass äh jetzt ähm
bei der auch vielen Rechenleistungen, die der Virus äh einsetzt, äh ja ähm
halte ich es für durchaus möglich oder wahrscheinlich, dass wir noch bessere Varianten sehen werden, also aus Sicht des des Virus, die halt erfolgreicher sind und als Erfolg zählt halt vor allem.
Ähm.
Die Verbreitung äh so und ähm da äh ist äh natürlich, wenn man sich jetzt äh anguckt.
Wie sich das Ganze verteilt, dann äh ist halt im Moment ein Großteil der Rechenleistungen entweder in Ländern, hm die schon mal äh wo schon mal eine ganze Menge Leute sich angesteckt,
und äh dort der Virus jetzt sucht nach Möglichkeiten, die vorhandene Immunabwehr äh zu umgehen, also sich sagen äh umzulabeln, wenn man so will gegenüber dem,
Immunsystem und als.
Völlig neuer, unbekannter Virus äh äh sich auszugeben. Das ist sozusagen die die eine äh Richtung, in der das äh Virus halt erfolgreich,
sein äh kann äh oder eben äh dann ja der Immunität, die durch äh,
hervorgerufen wurde, zu umgehen oder beides idealerweise und ähm da natürlich äh sehen je.
Wenn jetzt Länder da sind, wenn wir also bei uns,
jetzt oder auch in größeren Ländern oder wie in den USA wohnen, ein Großteil der Bevölkerung durchgeimpft ist äh und man äh trotzdem aber im Teil der Bevölkerung hm.
Hohe,
Inzidenzen weiter hat, äh setzt man natürlich auch Rechenleistung ein, um äh dann äh den die Geimpften sagen auch wieder äh fasten zu können. Das heißt, äh.
Ja, was.
Ich also erwarte ist, dass ähm bei weiter hohen Inzidenzen oder bei weiter steigenden Inzidenzen und weltweit hohen Inzidenzen wir einfach ähm ja
noch mehr Varianten sehen könnten, die hm vor allem immun Escape ähm.
Äh können, also,
Leute, die geimpft sind oder äh eben vorher erkrankt äh waren, äh schon mal, die dann trotzdem anzustecken. Wieder erneut.
Die Befürchtung haben wir ja schon lange, aber bisher hat sie sich ja nicht so richtig erfüllt, ne. Also es ist äh schon so die Impfstoffe halten noch dagegen.
Ja, ja. Äh die halten.
Prozent und so, aber wir haben wirklich eine extrem gute Abwehr eigentlich geschaffen und äh da ist die Natur noch am Knubeln,
Aber es ist so ein bisschen, wie du sagst, so mit dieser ganzen rechten Kapazität ja. Also jeder programmiert jetzt Viren. Das ist eigentlich wie so im informatischen
äh Bereich, ne, so wie,
das ist
Irre irgendwie und habe auch noch keine rechte Vorstellung davon, wie weit dieses äh Rennen so gehen wird. Ich habe bloß irgendwie das Gefühl, unser unsere Klaviatur ist so schlecht nicht.
Also es ist äh wir haben schon die Mittel, um es irgendwie in den Griff zu bekommen, wenn denn nur alle mitspielen.
Ja, es ist, ich meine, es ist aber, wie gesagt, ein ein Wettlauf, ein Wettrennen, was wir eben mit unserer,
Gesellschaft oder Gesellschaften und unseren ja,
Letztlich äh globalen Extraktionssystem einmal, äh wie die in der Lage sind, äh jetzt.
Den Virus zurückzudrängen. Ähm durch Intelligenz und Organisation und Forschung.
Und Produktion und Impfung und so.
Und auf der anderen Seite halt dieser Virus, der eben einfach mit äh Bluetooth äh Varianten durchprobiert. Boah.
Das äh gibt uns jetzt die Gelegenheit mal so ein bisschen äh in Richtung der Debatte äh zu kommen. Ähm.
Was sind sozusagen jetzt getan äh werden sollen, bevor wir jetzt vielleicht über Maßnahmen und die Frage, wie,
zu gesellschaftlich dem Ganzen begegnen wollen, wollte ich nochmal auf einen Artikel bei äh in Zeit Online verweisen.
Der mal so schön zusammengefasst hat, äh die aktuellen Erkenntnisse rund um Impfung
und äh entsprechende Kernaussagen daraus abgeleitet hat, nämlich zehn Stück, die durchaus Wert sind hier, glaube ich, noch mal kurz äh erwähnt zu werden.
Ist sagen wir mal so ein Artikel glaube ich den man sich also.
Viele Links und mit viel Details und Studien hast du nicht gesehen, aber wenn's euch einfach mal wieder darum geht, mal so ein bisschen den Kopf frei zu kriegen, um mal so einfach mal so ein klares Gerüst mit was ist denn jetzt hier eigentlich Phase und was ist denn jetzt eigentlich zu tun, äh wenn ihr sowas haben wollt, dann würde ich mal diesen Artikel
empfehlen.
Ähm ja, zehn Punkte sind das nämlich. Und mit relativ klaren und einfachen Feststellungen. Erstens, wer geimpft ist, lebt deutlich sicherer.
Ja, also es ist einfach klar, die Impfstoffe, die wir äh haben,
sind irgendwie ja, zu mindestens achtundachtzig Prozent äh äh effektiv, zumindest bei der Bevölkerung unter sechzig Jahren. Man kann sich damit halt einfach äh schützen.
Mehrfach aufgezählt, aber alle theoretischen Komplikationen, die diese Krankheit mit sich bringen kann.
Schwere Verläufe oder eben auch long covid. Wer sich impfen lässt, lebt einfach deutlich sicherer.
Und das bringt uns auch schon zum zweiten äh Punkt. Das Geimpfte ins Krankenhaus müssen ist selten. Ja, also das ist äh.
Großbritannien äh dreiundzwanzigtausend Geimpfte, davon kommt einer ins Krankenhaus.
So wie eine eine Zahl, damit kann man irgendwie äh anfangen. Man ist jetzt viel darüber geredet worden, dass Impfung ja nichts bringen. Man kann ja auch irgendwie äh sich infizieren und man kann's weitertragen und was nicht alles. Ja, stimmt alles, ist irgendwie alles äh möglich.
Nur, was euch jetzt persönlich betrifft, ähm.
So eins zu dreiundzwanzigtausend finde ich es irgendwie eine eine schöne Ansage, was die Wirkung von Impfstoffen betrifft. Das äh erspart euch einfach eine ganze Menge Ärger.
Drittens, die Impfung verhindert die meisten Corona-Fälle. Ne, also klar, man kann auch.
Infiziert werden und es kann diese Impfdurchbrüche äh geben. Man kann dann irgendwie auch äh krank werden, trotz alledem Impfstoffe äh,
helfen und hier wird die äh Rechnung aufgemacht, dass durch die Verimpfung sieben Komma zwei Millionen Infektionen in England äh gemeint ist wahrscheinlich okay, äh verhindert wurden.
Das hatten wir ja schon mal. Jede Infektion wirft Kosten auf, nicht nur für einen selbst, sondern vor allem auch für die Gesellschaft und damit dann doch wieder für einen selbst.
Verhindern das.
Viertens, wenige Neuinfektionen sind keinen Grund abzuwarten. Das ist ja, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen so ein Trend, so nach dem Motto, naja, es ist ja gerade nicht so viel los.
Da kann man sich ja irgendwie Zeit lassen.
Und das ist irgendwie, wie wir sehen, wie schnell die Zahlen auch wieder hochgehen können, einfach eine blöde Idee
erstens eine Doppelimpfung, die normale Doppelimpfung
Naja, das dauert dann halt einfach mal so fünf Wochen von dem ersten Stich, bis man wirklich den vollkommenen Impfschuss hat und in fünf Wochen kann der Spaß auch schnell wieder sich gedreht haben. Also, was heute eine niedrige Inzidenz ist, das äh ist irgendwie kein Signal, mit dem man das groß
aussitzen sollte.
Fünfter Punkt, Corona ist schlimmer als jede Impfreaktion, ja, also dieses ganze so, ja, ach Gott, und was kann denn die Impfung mit mir machen? Und dann fühle ich mich schlecht und dann habe ich Fieber und dann habe ich Kopfweh und so weiter. Ja,
Kann alles sein. Also ich habe nichts davon gehabt, muss ich mal dazu sagen, also so richtig überhaupt nichts davon gehabt. Aber wenn man's gehabt hat, dann bleibt's halt auch nicht lang. Es ist nach einem Tag oder zwei weg.
So Punkt sechs ähm echte Nebenwirkungen sind extrem selten.
Also hier ist ja auch noch mal klar, ich habe ja eben gerade gesagt, so ja okay, Impfreaktion, das ist halt das, was.
Unmittelbar auf die Impfung wirkt, ne? Und äh Nebenwirkungen, das ist irgendwie das, was immer so breit in der Debatte ist. Also, dass es irgendetwas auslöst, was jetzt nicht nur die unmittelbare Reaktion auf die Impfung ist, sondern in irgendeiner Form.
Schäden verursacht, Langzeitschäden. Wir haben das ja auch gesehen, äh den Fall mit diesen Venen, Thrombosen, bei äh der Impfung an sich gibt's jetzt eben auch noch die Sache mit den Herzmuskel
Entzündung.
Ja, das ist alles irgendwie real und es muss natürlich auch bedacht werden und das ist Teil dieses Risikos. Nur, dass dieses Risiko eben wirklich extrem,
selten ist. Also es tritt einfach selten auf und im Vergleich zu der Gefahr, die von der Infektion ausgeht, ist das wirklich zu vernachlässigen.
Äh siebter Punkt, die Impfung schützt wohl auch vor. Also,
ist ja immer im Mittelpunkt so, ja, schwere Fälle, nicht sterben et cetera, aber
es zeigt sich wohl auch, dass eben die Impfung auch entsprechend einschränken. Das ist äh, denke ich, auch ein ganz wichtiger
Punkt, weil viele Leute nehmen das ja auch nicht so ernst, aber es kann euch sagen, dass das will man einfach irgendwie nicht. Also man will nicht dauerhaft ausgeschaltet sein und irgendwie sich nicht konzentrieren können und so weiter, das ist
Das ist ja irgendwie äh richtig krass. Achter Punkt, kaum eine Vorerkrankung spricht dagegen.
Ist ja auch so eine Debatte mit so, ja, gibt Leute, die lassen sich nicht impfen und es gibt Leute, die können sich ja nicht impfen lassen. Und eigentlich ist so die einzige äh Geschichte, dass man sich nicht,
impfen lassen kann oder zwei Sachen würden mir einfallen. Das eine ist, man ist noch nicht zwölf und keiner impft einen oder
man hat irgendeinen nachweisbare Allergie gegen etwas, was in diesen Impfstoffen drin ist. So,
und das ist, glaube ich, das betrifft fast niemanden. Also es ist einfach, das wäre jetzt auch irgendwie.
Ähm
schon groß aufgefallen, wenn das irgendwie in nennenswerten Zahlen passiert wäre. Und ähm ja, allergische Schock, das das das hatten wir äh auch schon mal behandelt. Sowas kann passieren, ähm aber das dann auch in dem Fall auch behandelbar. Also wenn das Leute
schon wissen
dass sie dazu äh tendieren, dann äh machen sie das einfach in einer kontrollierten Umgebung im Krankenhaus und dann äh wird einem im Zeitsfall auch geholfen.
Neunter Punkt nachlassender Impfschutz ist besser als keiner. Ja
Kann man so sagen, also dieses Argument, so, na ja, es lässt ja dann auch irgendwie äh nach und es hält ja nicht ewig und so
alles sein, aber trotzdem, wenn man überhaupt erst mal ein bisschen Impfschutz hat, dann geht's einem äh auf jeden Fall immer noch besser, als wenn man noch nie einen gehabt hat. Und äh auch jetzt Monate danach alle
Daten aus Israel und Großbritannien besonders zeigen, dass dass also alles mindestens ein halbes Jahr hält und ich wäre auch ehrlich gesagt nicht überrascht, wenn wir noch sehen würden, dass es sehr viel länger hält.
Und letzter Punkt und den finde ich relativ wichtig.
Wer geimpft ist, schützt auch andere. Und das kommt mir in dieser ganzen Debatte immer wieder zu kurz und mir ist das auch alles ein bisschen zu Ego,
Dieses ich habe ja nichts davon oder ich brauche das ja nicht oder ich kann nicht krank werden oder was die Leute alle immer irgendwie denken.
Inwiefern sie da mit super Kräften ausgestattet sind oder irgendwas nicht brauchen.
Klar, so was dein Ego betrifft, das Individuum ist mir, das Schicksal ist Individuums, ist mir dann auch.
Erstmal egal, wenn ich die Leute nicht kenne, gut, wenn ihr da so draufsetzt, unbedingt krank werden zu wollen und dann werdet ihr krank und dann habt ihr einen Schaden so Pech gehabt.
So, würde mir mehr wehtun, umso näher mir diese Person steht, gar keine Frage. Aber ich denke, ein Hauptargument für die Impfung ist schlicht und ergreifend auch die, dass man damit eben einfach die Verbreitung,
ausgrenzt und andere unter Umständen gar nicht erst infiziert werden dadurch und das sollte eigentlich das Hauptargument auch sein.
Ja, ich finde, das sind gute zehn Thesen, mit denen man arbeiten kann.
Ja, also kann man, glaube ich, alles äh so unterschreiben an äh den,
Empfehlungen oder Erkenntnissen und ähm ja äh.
So, wir machen mal jetzt weiter. Das ist natürlich jetzt die Frage, die so ein bisschen äh steht, ne. Also jetzt haben wir viel über Inzidenzen gesprochen und irgendwie also ich bin jetzt zumindest drauf eingestellt, dass dass wir jetzt wieder so eine vierte Welle bekommen
vielleicht.
Wird sie nicht so stark ausfallen? Vielleicht gibt's auch noch irgendeinen Faktor, den wir noch nicht gesehen haben, der das irgendwie ausbremst. Vielleicht finden wir auch einen äh,
Umgang oder die Erfahrung,
mit den Regeln bisher Maske tragen und so weiter. Viele Tests machen, hält das Ganze in irgendeiner Form in Schach und dann haben wir so eine Situation mit zwar vergleichsweise hohen Inzeden,
Vergleich so, was wir,
schon gesehen hatten, nur eben mit deutlich weniger schweren Fällen und damit ist das Ganze Aufregungspotenzial nicht so groß, aber wir haben ja auch schon die Punkte gebracht.
Erstens, das Ganze ist exponential und selbst wenn wir das alles jetzt zehnmal besser im Griff haben, dank der Impfstoffe, ist halt Faktor zehn auch schnell erreicht bei exponentiellen äh Wachstum und das sollte man eben auch noch bedenken.
Wir wollen jetzt ja auch nicht nochmal eine deutsche Variante haben.
Also das fände ich irgendwie sehr uncool, so. Gut, die heißen jetzt alle nach griechischen äh Buchstaben
einen aussuchen, aber äh ich brauche das jetzt nicht unbedingt. Wir werden schon genug aus anderen Ländern äh bekommen, wo einfach die Impfsituation noch nicht so gut ist. Und das könnten wir uns irgendwie auch mal,
sparen. So und natürlich äh.
Schützen, die derzeit sich gar nicht impfen lassen können, sprich die Kinder, das äh steht bei mir ganz vorne an. Und das ist natürlich die Frage, wie geht man jetzt.
Vor behalten wir das Regime so, es gibt natürlich jetzt äh auch eine entsprechende Debatte, nur im Wahlkampf traut sich natürlich keiner, irgendwelche Entscheidungen zu fällen. Das heißt, wir werden so bis Ende September auf jeden Fall noch alles irgendwie im Eiertanz-Modus haben.
Verschiedene Ideen stehen im Raum, ja? Tests selber bezahlen müssen, Einschränkungen ähm nur aufheben für Geimpfte, ja?
Das sogenannte Impfangebot, von dem ihr immer die Rede war, dass es jetzt jedem gegeben worden.
Können wir jetzt mal festhalten. Also der Zeitpunkt, wo Bundesländer, Impfstoffe zurückgeben, heißt für mich,
hat jetzt die Gelegenheit äh gehabt, sich impfen zu lassen. Es gibt jetzt, Stand jetzt schon gar keine Ausrede mehr.
Ja sagen wir mal sagen wir mal, jeder jeder ab achtzehn ja, würde ich fairerweise.
Okay, da hast du einen Punkt, weil genau, okay, ja, mhm.
Selbst bei den bei den selbst bei den unter Achtzehnjährigen hatten wir ja äh gesagt, äh ja, viele könnten theoretisch, aber es wird ihnen schwer gemacht.
Okay äh äh es war aber auch bei diesem Impfangebot immer von äh Impfangebot an Erwachsene die Rede.
Ne, im politischen Diskurs, dann will ich das jetzt mal bisschen genauer fassen. Also die Erwachsenen, das sind ja auch die, die angeblich ja immer so vernünftig sind, ne. Äh die haben diese Gelegenheit jetzt gehabt.
Ihr seid jetzt noch nicht geimpft? Warum nicht? Was hält euch davon ab? So, ich habe verschiedene,
Paletten kennengelernt so. Ähm da gibt's halt so diesen notorischen, schlecht informierten Impfgegner, die wahrscheinlich auch nicht zu retten sind. Da gibt's aber auch so eine Gruppe von Leuten, die sind einfach verunsichert. Unter anderem von diesen notorischen.
Heinis, diesen Querdenkern und sonstigen.
Weiß ich nicht genau, welche Worte ich dafür noch äh finden soll. Die sind verunsichert, die sind unter Umständen auch, sagen wir mal, in so einem sozialen Kessel, in dem sie gar keine Möglichkeit haben, irgendwie groß rauszukommen und sich eine eigene Meinung zu bilden. Das ist dann
Kategorie tragisch? Da gibt's Leute, die sind ängstlich, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, ja?
Gut, kann ich nachvollziehen, man hört dieses, man hört jenes, der eine sagt das, die andere sagt das. Mhm, hm. Da ist dann irgendwie latent so ein bisschen Angst im Raum. Habe ich Verständnis für. Deswegen,
machen wir hier auch grade diese Ansagen, die wir hier gerade machen, die einfach sagen so,
ja, Angst, okay, gut, kann ich zwar nachvollziehen, nur man sollte einfach vor der Erkrankung,
Auswirkungen auf die Gesellschaft und auch sehr viel mehr Respekt haben als äh jetzt vielleicht vor dieser Impfung, weil die zeigt sich einfach in allen ähm Parametern
dass sie nicht so das Problem ist, ja?
Ja, sie kann theoretisch mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von so und so viel nach Roma stellen, ein Problem sein. Klar, nur all diese ganzen Wahrscheinlichkeiten
deutlich niedriger als das Risiko im Straßenverkehr einen Unfall zu haben, mit dem Flugzeug abzustürzen und so weiter. Das das sind so die eigentlichen Vergleichszahlen.
Ja natürlich so, du kannst immer entscheiden nicht zu fliegen, kannst entscheiden dich nicht zu impfen, aber dann setzen die Leute sich wahrscheinlich doch wieder ins Flugzeug und ins Auto.
Das ist so das, wo ich so ein bisschen meine Schwierigkeiten habe. Klar, alles, was so mit Nadeln und mit Pieksen und mit Körper und irgendwas wird irgendwo reingemacht. Das das das hat einfach so ein bisschen so ein Neid mehr potential
Aber bitte.
Es ist also um das mal so ein bisschen zu ordnen äh und sagen.
Sehe halt drei mögliche, wesentliche Wege, wie so eine Gesellschaft das angehen kann, die man alle auch irgendwie.
Durchaus äh verargumentieren kann, ja, wieso äh Weg,
Nummer eins bewehre und ich glaube, der wäre vielen auch durchaus sympathisch, wäre so der Staat,
haut mal mit der Forst auf den Tisch und sagt irgendwie jetzt äh irgendwie Schluss mit dem Gelaber, äh ja. Äh hier äh ja äh jeder lässt sich jetzt impfen.
Zwangsimpfung, ja? Und dann sind wir durch damit. Solange.
Impfen oder jeder wird.
Jeder wird geimpft so ja, jeder wird geimpft so wird nicht gefragt sondern wird geimpft.
Und wer nicht geimpft wird, äh bleibt zu lange in Quarantäne. Ja, so. Ja, so diese Kategorie. Das ist natürlich.
Ja? Dann wäre man in zwei Monaten äh wäre man halt äh durch mit dem ganzen Thema in Deutschland zumindest weit geht.
So ähm aber.
Nicht stattfinden, würde ich.
Nein, selbst, ich meine, selbst China, ja. Selbst China äh äh so äh äh wagt
das glaube ich nicht äh äh heut äh zutage. Äh wobei äh ja die ja ganz andere Dinge äh irgendwie da ihren ihren
Leuten zumuten, so mit Zwangsabtreibungen und andere Dinge. Da wäre eine Zwangsimpfung, glaube ich, hätten die noch das geringste äh Problem mit, aber machen's trotzdem nicht. Und ich glaube, in Deutschland.
Oder gerade äh nach den Erfahrungen äh ausm äh Dritten Reich äh so ähm muss man sagen, nicht alles, was irgendwie sinnvoll klingt, ja
ist auch am Ende des Tages wirklich äh sinnvoll, weil es gibt eben so ein paar Slipery Slows und ich hatte neulich ähm bin ich auf einen Artikel gestoßen, dass äh,
eben in der Nazizeit,
die äh Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jemand SS-Mitglied war, äh bei Ärzten oder Gesundheitspersonal zehn Mal so hoch war, wie in der, wie im Durchschnitt äh der Bevölkerung. Also
so speziell also was so die medizinische Profession so im dritten Reich, was was ist da an Lehren für für Ethik äh rausgibt,
äh das äh ja.
Lehrt uns eigentlich, dass wenn man einmal damit anfängt, das ist halt dieses Library Slope Geschichte so.
Und äh wenn man da nicht ganz klare äh Grenzen
setzt, so dann äh weitet sich das aus, dann äh geht es halt ja äh ging das halt in eugenische äh Geschichten auch äh rein, dass man dann äh
Also sagt, das ist gerade, ja, wenn's wenn's um.
Die die Hoheit über den eigenen Körper äh geht, die halte ich für absolut
und deswegen ist diese Lösung, die eigentlich äh ja äh jetzt rein rational gesehen, ja, wäre es äh sagen wir mal
wir ignorieren jetzt äh die Lehren der Geschichte und äh wir ziehen das jetzt einfach durch und sind dann durch damit. Aber ja, so.
Ähm das das ist geht halt nicht so. Ja bleiben halt.
Im Prinzip äh zwei andere äh Varianten. Das eine ist na ja, wir machen irgendwie so weiter wie bisher einfach, gucken mal und lavieren uns halt irgendwie durch
und ähm ja äh fahren auf Sicht, sage ich mal.
Die halt schlecht ist, also fahren weiter auf Sicht im Nebel. Ähm ja oder äh und das war jetzt, was äh sagen Jens Spahn, wo er halt laut drüber nachgedacht hat, äh war.
Zu sagen, was du erwähnt hast, ja.
Ab sofort äh ist jeder auf sich selbst äh gestellt, macht was ihr wollt. Ihr könnt euch impfen lassen und ansonsten habt ihr halt Pech gehabt. Wenn ihr euch nicht impfen lasst, dann äh ja, selbst Schuld.
Dann müsst ihr halt selber damit klarkommen.
Ja, wenn's halt nur die Leute selber werden, so, ne? Aber wir müssen ja da alle mit klarkommen, das ist ja das Problem.
Ja, na ja.
Aber das ist, wie gesagt, auch der, das ist dann sozusagen, ja, eher andere Standpunkt, der jetzt, ja, äh, durchaus an äh, äh, glaube ich, auch an gewisser Anhängerschaft gewinnt, aber am Ende
gibt's natürlich die äh absoluten äh Grenzen. Also in dem Moment, wo halt wieder die Intensivstationen volllaufen.
Spätestens dann muss man halt wieder was tun, spätestens dann sind alle Planungen oder alle Ideen oder oder Vorhaben, die man hat
sind dann halt Makulatur und ja und ob das passieren wird, also.
Die Zahlen haben wieder angezogen jetzt, das kann man, also die, die jetzt die steigenden Inzidenzen haben auch äh wieder äh bereits zu einer höheren Belegung der Intensivstation geführt,
und ähm ich sehe im Moment noch nichts, außer einer Impfquote von.
Dreiundneunzig, fünfundneunzig Prozent äh.
Oder einer deutlich höheren Impfquote auf jeden Fall, als die, die wir jetzt haben, äh die dem irgendwie dann Einhalt äh Gebieten äh würde. Also ohne so mein.
Meine.
Erwartung ist, dass äh ohne deutliche Fortschritte beim Impfen wir Inzidenzen und ähm ja auch wieder Belegungen von Intensivstationen.
Kommen werden, die nicht toleriert äh werden können.
Also brauchen wir Lösung Nummer drei.
Ähm na ja, das waren schon die drei Lösungen, oder?
Waren das schon die drei.
Die erste äh ging halt nicht, die zweite war, wir machen halt weiter wie bisher und die dritte war, wir wir machen halt komplett auf. Ich mein, gut,
Es gäbe noch eine Variante vier, das wäre, dass man dann äh versucht, äh endlich zu einer Strategie.
Zu kommen, äh global, aber ich glaube, der Zug ist auch abgefahren. So und das kriegen wir auch.
Ja gut, ich meine, das sind alles jetzt so Extreme. Ich meine, es wird jetzt zwangsläufig bis äh Ende September, weil jetzt Wahl ist, äh rechne ich jetzt in Deutschland nicht unbedingt damit, dass wir jetzt irgendwelche neuen nennenswerten Strategien äh bekommen werden, ne.
Alle wollen halt irgendwie und das ist ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht auch nachvollziehbar
Lockdowns verhindern und auch Einschränkungen, die auf bestimmten Branchen liegen. Ähm irgendwie vermeiden.
Ja, wobei ich immer noch denke, die Kultur ist immer noch am meisten getroffen und ist ja auch wieder das erste, äh, was leiden muss. Man hat das ja in äh Holland gesehen
wo ähm ja auch so wie auch in Großbritannien, so dieses Jahr Freedom-Day.
Wie erklären jetzt alles für beendet und dann wird das schon irgendwie passen. Hat natürlich überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Und äh,
Was war die erste Reaktion? Dann werden natürlich erstmal alle Clubs dicht gemacht. Was dann auch sofort,
feiert, weil darüber nämlich dann auch tatsächlich viele Infektionen passiert sind, weil das ist halt irgendwie drin und eng und Luft und so weiter, das haben wir ja alles schon, also es ist ja definitiv so, dass eben diese intensiven Indoor Aktivitäten.
Die ja dann im Winter gewisser Hinsicht unvermeidlich sind, wenn man sich mit Leuten treffen möchte
sind natürlich dann auch die größte Bedrohung und von daher natürlich auch das erste Opfer. Deswegen wäre es ja so sinnvoll, äh wenn man sich halt äh mehr impfen lassen würde. Und das ist auch, glaube ich, so der Hauptgrund, warum ich da so latent
frustriert bin von den Zahlen. Klar, man kann sich das jetzt äh schönreden und sagen, es ist doch eigentlich schon mal ganz gut so, aber wenn's halt auch noch besser geht, dann nehme ich gerne das besser.
Jetzt werden wir also in diese Situation kommen. Ja, wir werden dann irgendwann so eine Inzidenz von hundert haben, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was da in der Tabelle jetzt grade so mutmaßt, wie lange das jetzt noch dauert.
Vier Wochen.
Ja, also ich gucke gleich.
Irgendwie ein, zwei Monate, also bis zur Bundestagswahl, sind wir da auf jeden Fall.
Und dann klar, dann fangen sie natürlich alle an zu rechnen und sagen, naja, aber sterben ja nicht so viele und so weiter und Faktor zehn, Pipapo, da müssten wir ja schon bei tausend raus sein, so und dann wird's halt doch,
weiter verzögert werden, dann sind wir halt irgendwie bei vierhundert und fünfhundert und irgendwann fragt man sich halt so, ja, hm und jetzt.
Die selbe Situation, ja? Wir rollen auf den Winter zu, wir haben Probleme in den Krankenhäusern, die äh Intensivstationen, die ganzen Mitarbeiter, das Pflegepersonal, das äh intensiv
Personal, vor allem die
vor zwei Jahren völlig angekotzt waren von ihrem Job, haben jetzt überhaupt gar keinen Bock mehr. Wenn wir überhaupt noch so genug haben, also ich habe irgendwas gelesen von dreißig Prozent, wollen irgendwie kündigen, was anderes machen
jetzt irgendwie mal vielleicht mal was mit Holz ausprobieren. So, das heißt, wir werden da auch noch eine Personalverknappung sehen. Das macht jetzt die Situation nicht unbedingt besser. Also die Überlastung ist dann quasi noch, noch näher dran, weil einfach überhaupt gar kein Personal haben.
Oder zumindest nicht mehr so viel Personal haben. So und dann müssen wir ja natürlich jetzt in irgendeiner Form schauen, wie motivieren wir jetzt die Leute das Einzige zu tun, was uns in dieser Situation jetzt wirklich,
hilft. So und das einzige, was uns hilft, ist Impfung.
Sagen wir's doch einfach, wie es ist. Das Einzige, was uns hilft, ist Impfung. So, aber Leute wollen sich nicht impfen lassen. So, was können wir tun, um diese Leute dazu zu bringen, dass sie sich doch impfen lassen?
Ja. Ich meine, vielleicht ist die Idee von Jens Spahn.
Tatsächlich nicht die allerschlechteste zu sagen hier OK ihr habt so gewollt dann ja.
Dann bitte, dann äh ja. Äh vielleicht äh wacht dann der eine oder andere auf.
Meinst du jetzt mit äh ihr, ihr habt's so gewollt, also was ist jetzt die Konsequenz davon? Also.
Na ja, das äh sozusagen man äh äh tatsächlich dann ab einem bestimmten Punkt äh einfach sagt, wir äh behandeln das jetzt äh wie eine Grippe.
Wir machen deswegen nichts zu, wir heben halt, also jeder kann sich selber überlegen, ob er Masken tragen will oder ob er.
Sich impfen lassen will.
Ja gut, aber das heißt, wir wälzen das alles auf den Kindern ab.
Genau, das ist das geht natürlich nur sagen wenn auch 'nen Impfstoff für Kinder verfügbar ist und auch Schwangere sich zum Beispiel impfen lassen können so.
Ja gut bei Schwangeren hat sich das, glaube ich, auch schon so gedreht. Also ist zwar immer noch bei ihrer Empfehlung, aber mittlerweile, also ich glaube, die ganzen anderen Organisationen raten ganz klar dazu und es gibt eigentlich auch überhaupt gar keine Zahlen, die jetzt äh,
abraten, sich äh impfen zu lassen, wenn man schwanger ist.
Also.
Ja gut, also das ist halt noch nicht gegeben. Also ich würde dir glatz,
zustimmen und sagen, okay, besser wird's jetzt nicht mehr, äh weil alle haben ja die Gelegenheit gehabt, sich zu impfen, aber das ist jetzt halt nicht so. Wir müssen jetzt zwölf plus müssen wir noch mindestens einen Monat oder zwei geben, also das ist zumindest die
die Leute, die jetzt bisher schon zwölf waren
das dann auch äh wahrnehmen, auch wenn sie im Prinzip ja morgen alle anfangen könnten. Ähm bleibt aber dann halt einfach immer noch äh ein großer Bereich offen.
So und die Kinder jetzt dann einfach in Schulen zu setzen und zu sagen, so naja, also es wurde jetzt fast irgendwie,
Kaum jemand gefressen von einem Hai, dann könnte er jetzt auch wieder baden gehen. Ähm weiß ich nicht.
Also ich habe jetzt gerade nochmal die äh die äh Zahlen sagen für die, ich sage mal, Inzidenz,
Entwicklung, wenn das jetzt bei dem aktuellen R-Wert bleiben würde, was es natürlich nicht sein wird, aber es ist zumindest mal als als Anhaltspunkt ähm,
werden wir jetzt für äh äh Deutschland dann in vier Wochen bei zweiundfünfzig und in acht Wochen bei hundertelf äh Inzidenz.
Mhm.
So. Ähm.
Also siebenundzwanzig Tage bis fünfzig und zweiundfünfzig Tage bis hundert, das ist im Moment äh sagen die, die Berechnung, so. Wenn das jetzt tatsächlich so bliebe, also wir ungefähr, ich sage mal,
im Monat 'ne Verdopplung haben,
haben äh Größen oder alle drei Wochen irgendwie eine drei bis vier Wochen eine Verdopplung, dann hm.
Ja, äh dann könnte das noch ziemlich lange gut gehen, aber.
Darf nicht vergessen, wir haben immer noch Gegenden, wo die Inzidenzen sehr niedrig sind, die das Wachstum äh noch noch bremsen, das ist die eine Sache. Äh wir haben noch,
Sommer äh so. Wir haben also die Saisonalität, die das Wachstum noch bremst
und äh wir haben immer noch äh jede Menge Veranstaltungen, die nicht stattfinden können und äh wenn ich einkaufen bin, äh tragen alle Maske. Also es,
obwohl äh gut, mittlerweile die meisten Läden haben jetzt auf OP-Maske äh runtergestuft, aber es gibt halt trotzdem noch einen äh äh allgemeines Maskentragen, das heißt äh,
im Moment äh ja drücken wir halt auch noch durch zusätzliche äh Maßnahmen äh äh gerade das Wachstum,
würden wir damit aufhören, und äh der Wert steigt nur irgendwie ein bisschen äh an.
So, dann äh haben wir äh auch locker und äh zum Beispiel für Hamburg oder für Schleswig-Holstein ähm
sehen die Zahlen äh im Moment so aus, dass dort in acht Wochen die Inzidenzen.
Bei über tausend, beziehungsweise über zweitausend liegen würden, wenn das in dem Tempo ansteigt, also mit einem nur mit einem R-Wert von eins Komma drei statt,
eins Komma eins, ja? Oder eins Komma zwei fünf statt
eins Komma eins zwo, also ein geringer Airwertanstieg kann äh äh die Inzidenzen äh innerhalb von sechs bis acht Wochen äh über tausend Hochtreiben mehr,
locker.
Deine Berechnung jetzt eigentlich auch schon den äh Stand der Verimpfung.
Na ja der ergibt sich, ich meine das sind die, das sind halt die Zahlen
so ja die ergeben sich einfach rechnerisch aus dem Anstieg der Neuinfektion, insofern.
Ja, sind die Impfungen halt drin. Das einzige Jahr, äh, wie gesagt, was
im Moment noch für uns arbeitet, ist das noch äh durchaus geimpft wird, ja? Aber das ist der einzige zu sagen, äh das aber da das jetzt auch runtergeht, äh geht,
haben wir da ein Problem, dann
natürlich je mehr Zeit fortschreitet, umso mehr sinken auch die Antikörpertiter wiederum äh bei bei Leuten und äh ja, wie gesagt, Saisonalität, das wird demnächst kälter und wenn dann äh,
man noch mehr Maßnahmen jetzt aufgeben würde, sagen würde, wir lassen das jetzt alles so, dann bin ich mir äh ziemlich sicher, dann äh ja,
sind wir innerhalb von sechs bis acht Wochen an einem Punkt, äh wo dann doch wieder Lockdown äh passieren muss.
Gut, dann stellt sich jetzt die Frage, sollte es Maßnahmen geben, die in irgendeiner Form nicht nur so.
Jetzt machen wir mal, was wir wollen, sondern wir wollen schon irgendwie einen Schutz aufbauen, aber wir wollen die Leute auch motivieren, sich zu impfen.
Ich glaube, es gibt auch viele Leute, die sich nicht impfen lassen, obwohl sie nicht in diese ganzen Kategorien äh fallen, die ich vorhin aufgezählt habe. Also die jetzt
nicht äh besonderen Ängsten ausgesetzt sind oder irgendwie totale Anti-Gegner sind, sondern die einfach auch so ein äh weiß ich nicht, entweder immer noch nicht für das Problem sensibilisiert sind irgendwie der Meinung sind, das wäre nicht erforderlich, aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Irgendwie klar kommen, so ich bin ja nicht krank
ja, die es vielleicht mal hatten und ähm nie was davon gemerkt haben, kann ja auch sein, ne? Es gibt ja auch Leute, die dann
quasi so eine kostenlose Immunität, quasi eine kostenlose Impfung bekommen haben, weil sie ja zwar den Virus mal im Körper gehabt haben, aber davon wenig gespürt haben und,
trotzdem in irgendeiner Form resistent sind. Äh jetzt vielleicht von den neuen Varianten, aber eben auch wieder äh infiziert werden können. Also die verschiedensten Gründe und so eine so eine gewisse Lasernes ist da so drin. Aber in dem Moment, wo man einfach sagt, so Leute
Muss jetzt hier aber auch seinen Teil beitragen,
und der Aufwand ist jetzt echt nicht groß und kostenlos ist es auch noch und vielleicht gibt's noch eine Currywurst dazu, dann kann man da vielleicht dann auch schon mal sagen, so, naja gut, also wir.
Schränken jetzt Dinge an bestimmten Stellen nicht mehr ein, aber wir nehmen halt die Leute ohne Impfung da einfach raus aus diesen Öffnungen. Was hältst du davon?
Also ja äh es ist.
Aus meiner Sicht ist es schwierig, beziehungsweise äh hängt es davon,
ähm ja welches Politik oder äh Menschen äh Bild man äh grundsätzlich hat.
Ähm hegt man jetzt das äh Meer des Menschenbild, dass die Menschen äh
eigenverantwortlich und vernünftig äh sind und rationalen Argumenten äh zugänglich. Ähm so äh was wir ja wissen äh
nicht nicht der Fall ist, also definitiv nicht der Fall ist, äh so. Ähm was macht man dann halt mit den mit den Leuten oder inwieweit äh.
Inwieweit greift der Staat äh jetzt ein und äh zwingt einzelne Leute zu ihrem Glück, ja? So.
Das ist die Frage.
Und ähm ja und gut, da haben wir ja jetzt die Debatte gehört mit ganz, ganz vielen äh äh Maßnahmen, äh um halt Druck auf,
Leute auf, auszuüben oder Druck aufzubauen. Das meiste davon äh diskutiert. Ähm und,
fällt mir da wirklich, wirklich schwer äh so Position ähm,
zu beziehen an der Stelle sehr schlagen, wirklich verschiedene Herzen in meiner Brust.
Wir müssen ja jetzt nicht unbedingt eine eine Position beziehen, aber vielleicht kann man ja mal die Option benennen und mal so ein bisschen schauen, was was eigentlich das Problem damit wäre, ne. Den wollen wir einfach mal ein einfaches Beispiel. Äh Messebesuch.
So, derzeit hast du halt so dieses Ding, na ja, also entweder bist du halt geimpft, ja, oder du bist genesen, also du hast sozusagen eine nachweisliche Corona-Infektion äh mal durchgemacht. Äh oder du bist getestet.
Du gibst jetzt zwei Abstufungen. Kann sagen, na ja okay, also wenn du in eine Kategorie äh hat Impfangebot erhalten fällst, sprich achtzehn plus.
Dann entfällt getestet.
So, mit anderen Worten kommst da nur rein, wenn du irgendwie geimpft bist oder irgendwie eine Infektion nachweisen kannst. Du es fehlt so so die eine Ansage. Oder halt die etwas schwächere Version davon, ja, du musst dich testen lassen.
Ja, aber du musst dich irgendwie PCR testen lassen und zahlen musst du's auch selber.
Ja also.
Nur um mal jetzt so eine
Modell in den Raum zu stellen. Klar, da wird es Ungerechtigkeiten geben und da kann man jetzt auch drüber diskutieren, ob das so angemessen ist und ob das dann nicht auch schon wieder ein Zwang ist so, ne.
Weil man ja quasi in gewisser Hinsicht so ein Freiheitsentzug äh macht,
Ne, also im Sinne von, du darfst jetzt Dinge nicht, die du sonst durftest und du hast sozusagen keine Option, ohne jetzt selber Geld äh aufwenden zu müssen. Ist natürlich auch ein Problem, auch ein soziales Problem. Sehe ich auch, ne? Das das ist das Schwierige mit diesen nicht bezahlen wollen.
Aber irgendein Druck muss es äh.
Na ja, wir haben wir haben ja ich sage mal die, die.
Die allgemeine ähm Pflicht für die Ausübung bestimmter,
Tätigkeiten äh ein Gesundheitszeugnis beizubringen, ist ja nichts Ungewöhnliches oder nichts,
unzumutbares und in dem Zusammenhang wäre halt so eine Freitesten äh Geschichte äh äh glaube ich jetzt nichts, äh wo man sagen würde, das ist jetzt unerhört,
oder das das geht nicht, sondern das ist halt äh im im Prinzip etwas äh ja.
Was ich für zumutbar halten würde und was halt äh vielen Leuten eben zugemutet äh wird in anderen äh Kontexten.
Also das konkrete Beispiel, was du hast du gebracht hast, äh ja, äh sehe ich jetzt auch keinerlei rechtlichen,
Probleme äh drin.
Welche der beiden Varianten, die ich dir genannt habe, weil die Variante eins mit testen ist gar keine Option mehr.
Ach so.
Und Variante zwei ist, testen geht schon noch, so wie es derzeit ist, aber du musst äh für die Kosten selber aufkommen.
Ja, also äh sagen die die,
Die Tests Variante ähm also eigentlich gehen gehen beide Varianten.
Ja teilweise auch jetzt im zumindest im Reiseverkehr äh äh gibt's ja durchaus auch bestimmte Länder, wo Testen halt nicht geht. Ich meine, du hast,
Gut, du hast halt,
die die Belästigungsmacht durch Testen und die Belästigungsmacht, durch Quarantäne, die du in bestimmten Situationen halt verlangen kannst und die du dann halt äh ja.
Eben für für Geimpfte halt nicht gelten müssen. Wirklich sachgemäß
ist es eigentlich nicht. Ach so, du könntest dann noch, könntest du noch sagen irgendwie, okay, äh Geimpfte müssten auch noch keine in bestimmten Situationen keine Maske tragen. So.
Sinnvoll.
Ist das glaube ich alles nicht äh aus epidemiologischer Sicht. Das kann man, glaube ich, erstmal äh äh so so festhalten. Also jedenfalls äh,
nicht, nicht direkt und die Frage ist, äh sagen natürlich, welchen
Erfolg das das hat. Du wirst natürlich dann auch also
bestimmten Prozentsatz wirst du halt mit mit diesen Maßnahmen wahrscheinlich erreichen oder wird diesen Druck Druck nachgeben, aber äh das ist halt auch, wie es schon heißt, die also
du wirst damit glaube ich nicht alle kriegen oder nur ein Teil kriegen.
Nö, alle nicht, aber äh jeder zählt so. Und wenn wir jetzt mal äh fünfmal so hohe Zahlen äh hätten im Impfbereich, als wir es jetzt haben, wäre schon mal wieder etwas gerettet.
Ja
Also ich rechne ihr damit äh und das ist wahrscheinlich auch nach Maßgabe aller Dinge das politisch.
Vermutlich einzig durchsetzbare, dass es im Prinzip so weitergehen wird wie bisher, dass wir halt weit herum eiern äh werden,
und es wird sicherlich in dem Zuge damit rechne ich auch wird ein bisschen mehr Druck aufgebaut,
werden. Ich meine, die andere Variante äh natürlich ist halt durch Belohnung. So, da gab's ja auch viele Dinge. Es ist aber irgendwie in Deutschland,
glaube ich ist das nicht so der die große Akzeptanz zu Impfprämien oder so,
oder Teilnahme an der Lotterie dann oder was es da nicht alles an an Bonusmöglichkeiten.
Gebe.
Also ich meine, so richtig ausprobiert worden ist es ja noch nicht und ich finde auch nicht, dass man da äh so viel zu verlieren hat. Es traut sich bloß irgendwie so richtig keiner ran
weil wir halt jetzt in in dieser Phase, der niemand will irgendwas beschließen, um nicht seine Chancen bei der Bundestagswahl äh zu mildern Phase sind
So, das ist halt das Problem. Aber das ändert ja nichts an der Tatsache, dass man über paar Sachen einfach auch wirklich mal äh sich Gedanken machen muss.
Ja, ich meine, das Interessante oder Faszinierende an dieser ganzen Corona-Geschichte und jetzt diesen, diesem Impfproblem ist, dass es äh eines der wenigen,
ist oder ja, wo offenbar wird, das ist halt ein Haufen.
Wenn die sagen, ja doch, auch ein Haufen Idioten und einen Haufen irrationale äh äh Menschen äh gibt oder Menschen, die halt einfach komplett anders ticken äh,
und äh ja, normalerweise versucht man das in der Politik irgendwie nicht nicht zu erwähnen. Ja, also dass man irgendwie
eigentlich so Hauptsache dass die meisten Gesetze oder die Großteil der Politik eigentlich für Idioten
gemacht ist sowie Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung oder so.
Die wir ja nicht haben.
Ja, in den meisten Bereichen.
Ja, ja, aber wir haben sie halt da nicht. Also das ist im Prinzip da freie Fahrt für für alle Idioten.
Genau, aber in manchen, genau, aber äh ja. Aber man sieht halt, es ist das kann halt auch durchaus durchaus funktionieren. Nur hier
im Zusammenhang jetzt eben mit Corona sehen wir halt, dass das äh halt äh gewisse Grenzen hat und diese ganze Politisierung und Schweden hat's ja irgendwie probiert, so mit Eigenverantwortlichkeit und ach ja.
Das funktioniert einfach nicht besonders gut. Und ich meine, bleiben wir doch mal bei dieser Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung. Also da ist halt einfach diese Impfung äh würde ich dann durchaus mal in demselben Bereich sehen, ja. Also man muss einfach äh Leute davon abhalten,
sie hier mit zweihundert Stunden Kilometern durch die Innenstadt fahren. Und das ist halt das, was du machst, wenn du dich nicht impfst.
Also sozusagen Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung für das Virus.
Ja, genau. Wir brauchen eine Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung für das Virus. Tempo, Tempo dreißig, für Corona.
Ja.
Und schon wird alles besser.
Genau und das ist das ist die Impfung äh genau. Ja, also,
Ich ich fürchte,
ähm ja, die Menschheit ist also zum Untergang verurteilt äh und das ist der Grund oder es ist einer der Gründe, so weil egal, äh wie wir's jetzt machen, wie wir damit umgehen, äh so ist es eigentlich alles scheiße.
Ja ähm weil du, wie gesagt, eigentlich müsste es zu Idioten zwingen, aber äh kannst es nicht, weil das führt dann eben,
langfristig in den Abgrund äh und äh ja die Idioten nicht zu zwingen führt halt.
Kurzfristig abgrund.
Wird halt mittelfristig irgendwie in den ab.
Ja, hm, hm, hm.
Also es ist so ein bisschen äh deswegen ich mich äh grade damit schwer tue, weswegen ich wahrscheinlich auch
ja in der Politik dann
also nicht die richtige Person bin um jetzt Politik zu machen zum Beispiel so jetzt weil,
ja ich mich halt nicht entscheiden kann hier weil alles Scheiße ist.
Wobei eigentlich äh oder ich meine es die eigentliche Lösung hatten wir auch. Ähm eigentlich müssten wir ab morgen Lobdown machen.
Ist so. Ja.
Schöne Grüße an Stefan. Also äh ja aber wird nicht auch nicht passieren so, das.
Nee, wird nicht passieren. Nein, aber wir also, also das, was wir idealerweise jetzt äh sozusagen jetzt ein, zwei Wochen, äh, äh, einfach mal Lockdown, äh, ein, zwei Wochen, so, ähm, ja, Maßnahmen äh, äh, verschärfen.
Ein, zwei Wochen alles dicht machen. Dann können wir, dann haben wir nämlich den gehen die Zahlen nämlich auch erstmal wieder runter, dann haben wir ein bisschen Zeit und.
So konnten wir uns dann jetzt mit mit so ein, zwei, drei.
Ein, zwei Wochen Lockdowns könnten wir uns dann noch weit bis in den Winter retten äh und so ja, dass dass wir äh wahrscheinlich.
Äh nach noch immer das Vernünftigste, aber äh ja, wird nicht passieren. Ich weiß. So, ähm.
Immerhin gehen die Geburtenraten weiter zurück, also in Europa und USA zumindest. Das äh senkt natürlich dann auch äh die potentielle Zahl von Leuten, die sich noch infizieren können. Auch wenn das ein bisschen länger dauert.
Es ist super. Es ist super, ja. Ja, es ist.
Ja, es bestätigt so deine deine These, dass die Leute jetzt irgendwie eh vom Weltuntergang ausgehen.
Schauen wir mal. Na gut, aber jetzt äh sind wir schon wieder kurz vor Ende und äh haben's wieder nicht geschafft, hier die den positiven ähm Ausblick äh aufrechtzuerhalten.
Also immerhin haben wir nicht mehr so viel Grippe. Und Masern sind auch zurückgegangen. Hurra! Also.
Man sonst nichts hat, haben wir das.
Ja und ich meine am Ende.
Also ich glaube, ähm das Positive, um mal jetzt einen positiven Spin reinzubringen, äh so.
Wenn man sich impfen lässt und weiterhin die normalen.
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen wie Masken, in Innenräumen und nicht unnötig ja sich Gefahren aussetzen, dann hat man durch die Impfung Schutzfaktor zehn und durch die äh Masken,
nochmal Schutzfaktor ziehen
ungefähr und äh ja äh und wenn man äh für den Fall, dass man sich dann ansteckt ist auch nochmal ein Zehntel so schlimm, das heißt dann ist irgendwie Corona ist jetzt mit mit Impfung
und äh äh Maske ist nur noch ein Tausendstel so schlimm. Äh und eigentlich kann man.
Als Geimpfter mit Maske ähm eigentlich sagen.
Was kann mir die Welt, ja? Also.
Kann man auch sagen, sie interessiert mich jetzt alles nicht mehr. Ich bin geimpft und ich trage weiter Maske und ihr könnt mich alle mal.
Das sind die Superhelden von heute.
Bevor wir's hier ewig in die Länge äh ziehen, würde ich sagen, machen wir hier mal den Deckel äh drauf. Das war so ein bisschen unsere Zusammenfassung der Situation und wir gucken mal, wie wir uns jetzt hier wieder in einen Rhythmus reingetun bekommen. Ich äh
mindere gleich die Erwartungshaltung, weil noch ein bisschen Sommer ist noch und äh da will noch die ein oder andere Gelegenheit genutzt werden und der ein oder andere Termin ist unverschiebbar
bar, aber wir sehen jetzt zu, dass wir äh möglichst wieder am Ball bleiben und äh euch hier Informationen liefern können.
Ach so und ganz zum Ende sage ich auch noch mal, was heute das Datum ist. Heute ist nämlich der neunte August, das habe ich wieder im Eingang mal wieder total vergessen zu erwähnen. Ein Montag, ihr seht schon, wir sind ein bisschen aus der Spur, aber äh ja.
Podcast und dann äh machen wir vielleicht demnächst auch mal wieder unsere Runden auf äh Clubhaus, das fände ich ganz gut, um,
Wollen wir das äh vielleicht auch schon mal machen noch diese Woche?
Ja, könnten wir.
Ein bisschen kurzfristig den Dienstag anzukündigen. Und ich glaube, ich könnte nur äh Dienstag, das ist dann morgen,
ja, kann man ja einfach trotzdem mal machen. Wir müssen halt alle ganz schnell hören.
Äh morgen kann ich nicht.
Ach, kannst du nicht, ne? Machen wir das vielleicht nächste Woche drauf. Das passt.
In der Woche oder irgendwie so was. Alles klar. Könnt ihr alles auf Twitter lesen, der Podcast hat auch ein Twitter-Account, den könnt ihr sowieso mal abonnieren ME Unterstrich UKW,
oder ihr abonniert auch gleich äh Elfmeterebene auf Twitter, dann seid ihr dabei und natürlich könnt ihr auch diesen Podcast abonnieren, ihr könnt diesen Podcast auch
unterstützen durch eine kleine Spende, vor allem regelmäßige Spenden sind ja immer gerne äh gesehen, das findet ihr auf Meterebene ME Slash Spenden und,
mit den Worten lassen wir euch äh wieder äh in die Pandemie zurück. Äh viel Spaß noch mit eurem Sommer. Wir hören uns bald äh wieder. Bis dahin sagen wir tschüss und bis bald.